Building Games for
the Google Assistant,
May 10, 2018.
Building Games for
Building Games for Google
Assistant
good morning, everyone!
Thank you for coming so bright
and early at this 8:30 and thank
you for those watching along.
We're so excited to have you
here
because in the next 40 minutes
you will
be experts in Building Games for
Google Assistant.  We'll discuss
why we are serious about Play
and why you should be too.
And who is excited to play these
games, and we'll get into tips
of how, with words, Pixels,
sounds, the code to make it
happen.
Lastly, what you can do to be
found on the Google Assistant.
Before I go any further, I'll
introduce myself, I'm Thushan
Amarasiriwardena, I'm a product
manager for fun and delight on
the Google Assistant.
I'm joined by Andy, he's also
fun, he's our team's creative
lead.
Ralfi, he's our product manager
on dialogue flow.  While he
doesn't have fun in the
title, I guarantee to you he's
fun!
We're a really big team of
writers,
engineers,  designers, sound
engineers
that drive the personality and
delight of the Google Assistant.
This team crafts how we respond
to lots of queries like tell me
a joke to how are you doing and
surprisingly popular one, which
is hey,  Google, I love you!
People say that!
The reason we do this, you know,
you think of the Google
Assistant, everyone
thinks it is about getting
things done and that's
absolutely true.
We're here to make your life
easier, but we're also here to
make it a lot
more fun too and that's our
slogan for the team.
We build apps like trivia game
called Are you Feeling  Lucky.
The reason we do this, is that
we can learn how to make the
games and make sure that the
APIs that you need exist so it
that you can go build them.
We also build templates and we
worked with buzz feed recently
to bring them on board to the
Google Assistant and where you
can find out what dessert -- all
of the fun quizzes they have on
the site,
now you can play through the
Google Assistant.
We also work with awesome
startups
like Volley that made a game
called King
for a Day, one of the first that
run on the Smart Displays you
have seen around and we're
excited to show you those apps.
For example, they run on the
smart display right here and
they soon will be
running on phones and TVs.  We
have tried to make it easy for
you.  Rest assured, all of the
awesome Google actions you have
built can get upgraded with
ease, with technologies that
you're familiar with, HDML5 to
make that happen.
I'm sure many of you are like us
where when you were a kid you
wanted a talking robot.
I always wanted Optimus
capitol-based prime and now we
have
S prime and now we have it,
Google Assistant.  That's good
for us.  This is a favorite
chart.
Each curve is the adoption curve
of new technologies over time.
As you see, each one gets
sharper and has higher
adaptation rates as we get
closer to where we are now.
Then you look at us, smart
speakers.  While it is small
right  now, that curve is the
sharpest of them all.  People
are running to these devices
and adding it to their homes
around the world.
You probably think of the Google
Assistant as primarily coming
through
these, the Google homes and tons
made by third parties and that's
definitely the way to think of
us.   We want you to think of it
as it is more than those
devices.   The assistant is
everywhere, on the kitchen, on
the Smart Displays, in the
living room on TVs and most
importantly, it is on the go, it
is in millions and millions of
people's pockets on their
phones.  We think that's an
opportunity to reach users in a
variety of modes, in a variety
of places and we believe it is a
new type of play.  We call it
conversational play.
While we feel we're in the black
and white film era of this,
we're still learning how to go
build the games.  We do know a
couple of things.
When we look at who our users
are, we're seeing patterns of
who they are.
They're millennials, they're
families
and kids, perfect game players.
We also want to highlight this,
this
is Angry Birds rise to fame.
What's important to note, it
took a
while before Angry Birds became
one of
the seminal games on touch
screens.  Smart phones were
released and it took
about two years before Angry
Birds came
out and riseed.  This is where
we are right now.  Smart
speakers have been out for a
while, there is an inflection
point we believe will happen
particularly around play.  We're
down there, and we believe that
one of you, many of you,
hopefully all
of you, will be on that curve
coming up.
So I'll hand this off to Andy
who will talk about building
Blocks of play.
>> Andy: All right. Thank you.
I'm Andy.  I'm also officially
fun!  What I would like to do is
talk to you about the building
Blocks of great conversational
game play.  There's going to be
unique challenges that make
designing conversational games
very different than your
console, PC or mobile games.
Here are some of the principles
that our team uses to delivering
engaging
experiences that users love.
First, we need to create the
universe.  Think of some of your
favorite games,
what are the worlds that they
transport you to?
Some old school favorites, Dark
Castle,ers Space Quest and
Zelda.  There is an oaker
strayings of elements through
the backgrounds, characters, the
story, the sound, they all work
together.  They often rely on
visuals to bring
this world to life.  Now with
conversational games we don't
always have those elements to
work with.  We have to look for
inspiration elsewhere.  One of
the places that we can look, it
is the oral story telling
techniques that go back hundreds
of years.
A simple story starting phrase,
once
upon a time, it sets the stage
in fairy tales, tables and
myths.
The origins date back past the
1400s and they're pretty much
universal.
You can find equivalents in
dozens of languages, things like
a long time ago,
there once lived, so for uses to
create our universe, we need to
set the stage just like once
upon a time does for fairy
tales.  It doesn't need to be
much, it does
help users understand the world
they're in.  Here is a quick
example.   If you ask the
assistant what should I be for
Halloween, it is going to go
through a series of questions
and help you decide a silly
costume to wear when you go
trick-or-treating.  Here are two
approaches on bringing the
player into the game.
Let's listen to the first one.
Welcome to the Halloween
costume quiz, answer these five
questions to find out
what you should be for Halloween
this year.
>> Andy: That technically does
the job, it brings the user in a
little bit.  It also at least
gives feedback to threat users
know that they entered the right
game.  I think we can do more.
Now let's listen to this second
option.
>> Well, I'm so glad you asked.
I don't want to tout my own horn
but
I'm -- toot my own horn but I'm
kind of as expert.
>> Trick-or-treat.
>> Nice costumes, great use of
burlap.  Here you go.
>> Thank you.
>> Run along, have fun. I
need to help someone now.
>> Bye. Okay. Let me assess
your costume interests with a
few questions.  Are you ready?
>> Listen to how that second
version really starts to set the
stage and more importantly, it
gets users excited about
playing the game.
The other thing we really need
to do
is to kind of look on ways to
layer in sound design.  It is
such a critical element,
especially since we have fewer
elements to work with.  We have
to look at ways to paint this
audio world.   This can be done
in a couple of ways.  One,
through the background, music,
atmosphere, really helping to
create that whole affect, or we
can also use it as a foreground
element.   Maybe wanting to use
it as a way to give feedback to
the user that they have done
something write or wrong or we
want to use it to empathize key
moments of delight or dialogue.
To illustrate this point, the
Google Assistant has a  poem for
you, our loving audience.  It is
titled bikes and kick stands.
Let's listen to this.
>> Thank you for humoring.
Give me a few seconds to write
it down.  You're like a bike and
I'm like the kick stand, lean on
me, friend, when it is time to
make plans whether you're
searching for info, trying to
spell sha
toe, looking for necessities or
others, I will always reply.
>> Pretty good. Let's hear it
with sound layered in.
>> Thanks for humoring me, just
give
me a few seconds to write it
down.
You're like a bike and I'm like
the kick stand.  Lean on me,
friend, when it is time to make
plans.   Whether you're
searching for info, trying to
spell sha toe, looking for
recipes or other necessities, if
you
have any questions, I'll always
reply.
.
We'll later on show you how to
add the love in your dialogue.
Another thing to consider, how
to use sound to let  users
focus.  This is helpful in
multiplayer experience.
In our game are you feeling
lucky
users are given names, since you
have 6
players at a time, we found
through research that users may
forget when it is time to
answer.  To help get users to
focus we pair them with audio
queues.
Let's listen to how that works.
Okay.  Just so everybody is
straight, I'll give you your
names again.
They are Nibbler, scooter,
freestyle, puddles.
>> This can be a great way to
just kind of associate that
audio queue with that name,
bring users back and it is
something that you may want to
consider as you're developing
games too, how to
use audio queues to get users to
focus.
Now our next principle, it is to
keep it simple.
Conversations, they're
inherently linear.  It is really
easy to move forward and it is
much harder to move back.  We
can't ask users to hold too much
in their heads.  Here are a few
ways that you can keep things
simple.
The first, use a consistent
structure.  Familiarity is going
to make people feel more
comfortable.  The more we have
deviations, it is going to
increase the cognitive load of
the player and a higher level of
confusion or possibly errors.
Imagine this, we're in a quiz,
here are just two different
questions, pretty
similar in structure.
Now we restate that question, we
follow-up with the options.  We
still kind of vary the language
a little bit.  We see the
structure is very consistent.
So as the player   goes through
the experience, they're now
going to know what to expect,
allowing them to focus
on the content and not the game
mechanics.
As we push the boundaries of
conversational game play, you
may want to change the
structure.  Maybe you want to
have a bonus round, something
like that.  That's going to be
okay as long as you take the
time and teach the users that
this portion of the game is
going to be  different.  You're
going to need to ultimately
weigh is that worth it, is it
worth it to take that time to
explain it even though it may
slow the pace down a little bit.
Another simple thing to keep in
mind, when you list out the
choices for a player, just make
sure you follow-up with the
exact order.  If you look at
this, would you rather
travel on a tiny plane or surf
board, we follow-up with plane
and then surfboard.  Sometimes
it is easy to switch those
around but keep it consistent.
.
The next principle is to keep
players engaged.  We don't want
the games to feel like a
lecture.
It is easy for players to get
distracted.
A way to do that is analyze the
player experience through the
game.  If you came from the game
world you may be familiar with
the player interest curve, it is
a way to represent the
highlights and the  lowlights of
a player's experience.  This is
going to be similar to kind of
creating user journey maps if
you're familiar with product
designs and some
of that, it is similar types of
concepts.  You will simply watch
players playing your game and
you will notice kind of key
milestones, watch the reactions,
are they cringing, excited, you
will start to plot this.  As you
do this, you're going to
generate the patterns, as the
patterns happen, you will want
to make sure that the curve is
up.  Looking at a graph like
this, this is a bit of a
concern.  You see it starts off
with a great intro, and ends
with an outcome and the middle,
it sags a bit.
We don't want that to happen.
One way to keep players engaged,
it is to make the player part of
the conversation.  You know your
experience will be directed by
the dialogue.  We want to make
sure that we're always talking
with the player and not at the
player.
You can do this by creating
digestible chunks.
You find moments for your player
to participate.
The other thing we can do,
respond contactually whenever
possible.  Craft the dialogue
based on that  player's
response.  Imagine here, the
player is asked if they would
rather play with a unicorn or a
dragon.  Here we have a very
generic response.
This could be something for any
of the questions.
However, in this example, we're
able to respond to something
that's not just a bit more
delightful but it makes the game
feel smarter.  It is providing
simple feedback to the
user that the game understands
what they said.
Now as we move to more visual
experiences, Smart Displays,
what we
want to do is avoid transcribing
word
for word all of the dialogue.
We had mentioned the buzz feed
quiz and this is an example, on
the right,
this is the TTS, this is the
output.  On the left is the
experience itself.   You can see
we're not just using the screen
to throw all of that text in, we
want to simplify it, move the
user forrd with a, we want to
use the screen to create that
universe.   We want to make sure
there is opportunities to
increase the brand and create
more of an emotional connection
with the user.
Don't transcribe your text word
for word.
Another way to keep players
engaged, is to have a great
pay-off.  Our user's time, it is
very valuable and there is a lot
of competition for it.  We have
to make sure that we award them
forgetting to the end.  If you
remember that interest curve we
were showing before, it ended on
the high note.  You guys as game
designers are going
to figure out what that pay-off
is going to be.
The last principle, it is to
always be play testing.   In the
game industry this is nothing
new.  We know it will help
increase quality,
we know it will help find bugs,
basic design flaws.  We also
know that engagement is going
to drop off if the game feels
broken.  We expect that errors
will happen.  Especially with
conversational games, we know
that players will respond with
anything.
The environment may be polluted,
full of background noise.  We
definitely got a bit of that in
the sandbox and you can kind of
hear all of the people around,
you know, there is going to be
situations like that if you're
at a party and it may be tough.
You have to anticipate some of
that.
We know players may forget what
to do next.
A few common errors we see are
things
like no input errors where the
assistant hasn't detected a
response at all.  We see things
like no match errors where the
assistant can't understand the
reply and we also get false
accept errors.
This may be where the assistant
misunderstands the user and
moves along anyway.
Here is a few things we can do
to
minimize the errors and maximize
the fun.  One, start with your
concept and you
can do this in a very low way.
Have a user, players, read the
script of kind of the happy
path, essentially the ideal path
of the game play.  You need to
make sure that the game play is
actually fun.  If the happy path
isn't happy, then it
may be time to look at ways to
it
iterate on it.  The other thing
we do, we test with our eyes
closed.  These are
conversational games and we
start with designing for voice
only.  We do this with a working
prototype so things like
dialogue flow or you can do
this as a wizard of Oz technique
where a team member may
stimulate the response of the
system and you ever it set up in
the controlled environment.
This is a great way to test
the content, the pacing and the
complexity
of the game mechanics.
The last suggestion here, it is
to
test with a range of audiences.
Not the primary demographic.
Watch the parents play with it,
parents play with it, they may
bubble up issues of the
comprehension, complexity of the
dialogue and may discover that
some words are hard to say.
To wrap up really quick, some of
the basic building Blocks that
our team uses
are create the universe, keep it
simple,
keep users engaged and
consistently play test.
I'll hand it over now.
>> Hello, everyone. I'm also
fun!
Now that we're equipped with the
expert tips from Andy, let's
dive into how we can actually
implement all of this.
Good news, starting is really
simple.  We're working really
hard on developing tools and
capabilities to make it easier
for you to focus on what
you do the best, developing
games.  At a high level,
developing actionless
for Google has three main
components, this applies to any
action, games or non-games.  The
first, you have to build the
dialogue flows and then you need
to connect the flow to the game
logic and
lastly, you need to publish your
actions to Google Assistant.
For the rest of this talk, I'll
focus
on dialogue flow, our industrial
leading it creation program and
actions on Google console, a
tool that you publish
the actions to Google Assistant.
Dialogue flow is a tool that
makes it easy to build
conversational flows extracting
meaning from dialogues, applying
machine learning to the training
Examples that you provide.
Let me show you how it works.
Imagine you say the following
sentence:  Send three dragons to
edge lend immediately.
Attack with green flames for
five hours.
Dialogue flow, this is about
game term, not about user asking
for help, trying to exit the
game, it is about game term.  It
identifies important concepts
within the dialogue.  It
understands common concepts like
numbers, countries, colors, and
examine extract specific
comments on the game
like characters, weapons and is
understanding time, when you say
five hours, it resolves it from
the time that
the sentence was authored to
five hours later.
The cool thing about dialogue
flow, it
comes with built-in
internalization support.  With a
click, you can transcribe that
into a other language.  If you
want to learn more, you can go
to a session at 3:30 on Stage 2.
Now that you have built the
action, it is time to test.   Up
until now, you could only test
the
actions using your own developer
account on devices aassociated
with that.
We released a new feature
allowing you
to share your actions with other
users.  This is good for testing
and design and development
phase.  There are no policy
reviews and that's the quickest
way to get to the testers
and get feedback and it erate.
The beta release is for games
ready to launch, it goes through
full review process, it is to
find bugs and issues and
ultimately we want you to
produce
the best game possible.
After you build, test, publish
you're effectively part of the
Google ecosystem.  You should
make the most out of that.  The
easiest way to do that is
account linking and allowing
your users to use their own
Google accounts to play your
games or they can link the
Google
account to your account
management system.
To set up account linking, go to
the linking console and you can
define what permissions you plan
to ask from user and these
permissions are defined as
scopes.  For example, we can ask
for access to user  contacts,
calendar, photos, other
Google services that they may be
using.
From a user perspective, they go
through the familiar Google flow
to use
their own Google account or link
that to the gaming account.
Creating this experience as a
developer is fairly simple, just
literally two lines of code and
use the sign in help function to
request the sign-in.  Once you
do that, you need to handle the
user's response.  If the user
goes through the authentication
flow successfully, you receive
an access token to use to access
the resources that you asked
permission for.
If something goes wrong, you
need to
acknowledge it, and gracefully
exit.  A key to Google Assistant
is the fact
it is available in various
mobilities
and actions on Google IEs gives
you control on handling the
interaction types.
We'll quickly go over the
different interaction types.
The first one, what we call
voice only.  You can think of
the smart speakers
and the whole interaction is
voice space, input and output.
The second interaction, voice
forward, these are smart
speakers you see in the sandbox
area.  Here, again, the primary
mode of
instruction is voice and has
with visuals when necessary.
The third interaction model is
intermodal, think of the phone,
here you
have conversation and visuals
enter visuals inter mixed, you
go back and forth.
The last one, it is visual
only.
You think of the phone on mute
as an example.  Here there is no
audio input or
output, it is all about visual
and text.
Let's go through an example.
Let's say that a user is playing
your game on a smart speaker and
then you
want to show them the image of
their new monster evolved.  We
define the image here.
The first thing we need to do,
we need to check if the device
the player is playing the game
on has a capability to show an
image.
This capability is defined as
screen output.  If the device
has the capability, great.  We
show the image.  In our example,
the player is playing on a smart
speaker which doesn't have that
capability.
What we do, we ask the user to
switch the device to one that
has this capability.  We do this
with the function called new
surface.  With he define what
capability we're looking for, in
this case, screen output and we
give the context to the user on
the smart speaker they're
extracting
with to see the evolved monster
go to the phone.  Then we send
the notification to the device
we want to take the user to.  In
this example we say see how the
monster has evolved and they
continue
the interaction on the phone.
The final step as a developer
is to
manage the flow, and it is to
handle the response off the user
for the new resurface phone, if
the user accepts the prompt,
moves to this new capable device
and you simply show the image.
If they don't, you just need to
gracefully exit and acknowledge
that you
won't be able to show the image.
Once the game actions start to
get traction, you need to think
about reengagement.  We have
multiple ways in the platform
to help you reEngage with your
users.  We literally have a
section called
user engagement on the action
console.   There you can push
notifications, routines, data
updates and suggestions.  If you
push notifications, you will be
allowed to send notifications to
the users.  Obviously the users
need to provide consent.  This
is a powerful tool.
It needs to be used thoughtfully
and sparingly.  You of think of
routines as actions come
together.  We have something
like I'm home routine, where you
can bundle a bunch of apps you
want to trigger and if you say
hey, Google, I'm home, you may
have Google turn on the lights,
adjust the thermostat, tell you
a joke maybe and
start your favorite play list.
This is similar.
You set up a daily notification
that reoccurs every day at the
set time.  The user experience
for daily routines and daily
updates and routines is that
after the users Engage with your
app and exit they will see a
suggestion prompting them to add
your action to
daily updates or routines.
Routines may not be that
suitable for gaming vertical but
something you think about.  I'll
just focus on the daily updates
for now.
This is what you will see,
what the
users will see if you opt into
the daily updates.  After the
user, as the interaction, there
is a chip that says you want me
to send in this case jokes
daily, if the user opts in,
Google will guide the user
through setting the time of the
day when they want to receive
the daily update.  From this
point on, as a developer, we
need to do two things.  First,
you need to handle the daily
response to the daily update
flow.  If the user goes through
the flow successfully, you
acknowledge that, if
not, again, you need to
gracefully exit.  The second
step, you need to define what
you actually want to do when the
daily trigger arrives.
Here we set the trigger to the
update intent.
The best example, the update
intent would just send a new
job.
Ultimately, this is what the
users will see.
Lastly, I would like to talk
about monetization options for
the game.
We just announced the digital
goods
API that allows you to use the
Google play ininterest framework
structure building on the
earlier launch this year where
you could use your existing play
entitlements with assistant
actions.
For example, if you bought an
audio
book or purchased a monster in
the game,
you could actually use it in
Google Assistant.  What digital
goods API does, it makes the
rethe verse also true.
If you have a Tran action
transaction, the same
entitlement is used in the
Android app.
Let's go through an example from
the partners in head space to
show you how this could work on
a smart display.  For those of
you that don't know about
head space, they're a company
that built
products on guided meditation.
So let's say that the session is
over
and head space offers the option
to subscribe.
The user responds with an intent
The action shows available
options in a curated, visual
way.  The user picks an option
and it is
handed over to the checkout
flow.  Here if you enable the
account linking and the user has
account credentials stored with
Google, the check out will
be very seamless, a single tap,
a command, you will have the
proven
content that can be reused on
the assistant and on Android
apps.
With that, I'll hand it back and
we'll talk about implementing
some best practices in the
games.
>> THUSHAN AMARASIRIWARDENA:
Now we'll pump it up.
You remember back when Andy
was talking, we showed the
difference of what the sound
design can do.
The devices really rely on
music,
sound affects and voice.  We
have some technology that we
wanted to showcase that can help
you pump it up quite a bit.  You
could, for example, record tons
and tons of lines with a voice
actor and get a sound engineer
to add sound affects and make
some beautiful audio, or you
could use this technology called
SSML which is which allows you
to do it in realtime
in code and it also allows you
to put variables along the way.
We have this static poem, it
says
thank you for humoring me, you
can add personalization and yet
have the dynamic sound affects
and all.
Here is the script.  We'll start
pumping it up.
SSML is just like HTML but you
add
tags, you wrap it in a tag and
you put paragraph tags when you
have each line and then you can
start doing things like
adding sound affects and it is a
simple
audio URL from the server.
There's more than just text and
sound affects, there's sound
layering and that's what we'll
talk about here.  We have a tag
called media.  What media does,
it allows you to
essentially make two multiple
tracks and layer them together.
This is our first track here.
We'll call it poem.  It will
start one second in and you will
see why in a second.  We have
another sound affect and we'll
put a dramatic pause.
We work on our music loop.  We
call it music.  We can control
how many times it loops through.
You set the sound Level if we
want it
to fade in or fade out and then
we use
that name from earlier when the
poem ends let's run it for
another second and
then we have the music loop
itself.
Altogether, we wrap it in what
we have
as another tag, par, it is
running both tracks together.
What I showed you here, it is a
you truncated version of the
humor.
>> Thongs for humoring me, give
me a
few seconds to
Thanks for humoring me --
>> We have the music, the
sound affect -- we have the
plans.
>> Looking for recipes, other
necessities, if you have any
questions, I'll always reply.
>> THUSHAN AMARASIRIWARDENA:
That fade out.
It is all done in code.  The
other big thing to leave you
with, it is if you make
something and no one hears it,
not only is that a punch in the
gut, but you're wondering what
you can do to make that happen.
We want to tell you that very,
very soon we'll be opening up
hey Google,
let's play a game to all
developers.
This is called a built and
intent, there are other talks
about it t register your app for
it.
Consider it the App Store of
games on the Google Assistant.
When someone says play a game,
which is what a lot of the users
are  doing,
they'll get a list of the games
available, and this works on the
Smart
Displays, phones, smart
speakers.
To make that happen, we have a
little homework for you.  Go
back into the actions on Google
console and fill out all of the
metadata.
That's what we use to look at
your app, know what it is about
and feature it with users.  Make
sure you have beautiful icons
and
the descriptions are great
there.
I'm going to tell you a little
secret.
We don't  usually talk about how
we rank things but I want to
highlight this.
This is how we look for quality.
Straight-up quality, be it -- it
sounds great, the game play is
great and users love it, rate
it, we're looking for long
sessions and games that have
people coming back for more and
more.  We're looking for games
that map to the core
demographics, millennials,
families and kids and we're
looking for games that aren't
like the others around there.
We want to offer our users a
wide variety of games.  If you
can update your apps regularly
and feature the new tech like
jumping on the Smart Displays,
that gives you a
great shot of getting in front
of users.
We want to leave you with one
last note.
I think many of you have been on
the
touch screen revolution of
making apps and we think there
is an opportunity very similar
here with the smart
speakers and digital assistants.
On behalf of the dialogue flow,
the action on Google team,
assistant, we know that it is
hard, but we're here for you.
We want to see you succeed.  We
would love to hear from you.
I'm going to show you our email
addresses later.  We think there
is an opportunity to become the
household name of conversation
and play and games and we
want it to be you, all of you.
Thank you so much.
Please leave us feedback, take a
snapshot of the email addresses,
we
would love to hear from you be
it new
tech or questions on how to use
it and apps that you're making,
we would love to play with them.
Thank you so much and we can't
wait to play your games!
Sites for the Modern Web
Sites for
the Modern Web
.
>> Hello, everyone! Thank you
for being here!
We're excited to speak with you
about how e-commerce can take
advantage of the new next
generation tools we have worked
on to build effective websites.
I work on partnerships for
mobile web
technologies like accelerated
mobile pages or amp or PWA.
>> I'm a developer advocate
for web and Chrome.
>> We're on day three, you have
heard what Google is up to this
week from
driverless cars to the assistant
to the latest on the Android
platform.
Connectiveity is what brings
this together.  You can ask
about the baseball score,
message friends or ask Google to
play music.  An important thing
we do, connecting people to
goods and services that they
want to buy and connect
businesses to a new customer
base.  Our goal at Google is to
bridge the gap between users
that want to know something or
find something and the companies
that have the information
they're looking for.
We do that with a variety of
services,
including some that are listed
here.
Our bread and butter remains the
open web, the greatest content
discovery platform that's ever
existed.  The open web doesn't
always live in browsers, web
views on a phone but powers much
of the content that drives
surfaces like Search and
Assistant.  Why the web?  It is
free.  It is  open.  Anyone is
open to come make their mark on
the web.   Most importantly, the
reach is enormous.  There are 5
billion devices connected to the
open web, and that number is
growing at a steady rate.
In e-commerce specifically,
there is a massive amount of
business taking place online.
Majority of user time on resale
happens on the web both desktop
and mobile.  In that category,
with he know mobile is growing
at a steady rate.   We know that
while we love apps at Google not
every user will download new
apps in a given month.  If
you're able to get a user to
download the app, great,
continue to focus on building
the best experience for loyal
users who have your app and
working on a download strategy
for the
apps on Android and iOS but the
reality is that most new users
come in via the web and you make
that a killer experience for
them so that they Engage with
the brand and come back again
and again.  That ultimately may
lead to them downloading the
app.  The web gives you an
opportunity to reach a huge new
user base and that's why we love
it for the commerce space.
However, as great as the web is
for facilitating an open
dialogue and ensuring a level
playing field exists for anyone
who wants to publish content and
as great as it is for allowing
brands to reach audiences they
never could  have, there are
challenges that place the future
of the open mobile web in an
uncertain place.  The essence of
that challenge, it is engagement
and capabilities which to date
have not been on par with the
engagement and capabilities of
apps.  You get great
unparalleled reach with the web
but a lot of the time the
engagement isn't where you would
like to see it.
That's changing.  The tools that
allow you to have great
engagement on the mobile web
exists and over the next 30
minutes we'll talk about
building the technology in the
web presence today.  The
ultimate goal is to improve
engagement on the web so it
meets or
exceeds that of
native apps and keeping
everything that the web has.
We'll keep the reach, staggering
engagement, in theory, a perfect
world.  In practice, the web has
a lot of issues and it is a tall
order to combat all of the
problems.  We're approaching the
challenge head on and there is a
lot going on.  You see a few
examples here.  Scrolling is not
responsive, pages
load slowly, content bounces
around when
late images or ads pop in and it
doesn't work well offline or on
flakey connections.  On top of
that, while  technologies exist
to improve the performance and
engagement of websites we have
not always made it easy for
developers to take advantage of
the solutions so they're not
always put into practice.  We
know at times these solutions
can be complex, and they're
changing a lot, there is an
awareness issue of the latest
best practices.
Overall, that makes it difficult
to understand with the return on
the development investment will
be or what the ROI is in terms
of dollars.   We want to clear
up that confusion today.
Enabling some of the new web
technologies could have a had
meaningful impact for the
business.  Poor performance has
real life
containers queenses, as you see,
over 50% of users bounce from a
site that takes more than 3
seconds to load and 79% of them
will abandon that site if they
find it difficult to use.  In
terms of revenue, we have seen
that
there is a 7% drop in total
revenue for everyone second
delay that every user  faces, it
is a had major user.  Users are
not finding what they want,
either because of a page not
loading or
the experience after load was
less than stellar and they're
leaving sites sooner than they
otherwise would have.  It is a
huge missed growth opportunity.
Loss revenue that affects the
growth of the business is
obviously important but not the
only factor here.  This slide
runs through a bunch of
experiences that brings stress
to people and they include
waiting online in a
retail store, watching the
melodramatic TV show, standing
on the edge of a virtual cliff,
watching a horror movie and
experiencing mobile delays.
That's  correct, somehow the
level of stress caused by mobile
delays was comparable but
slightly worse than watching a
horror movie and it is only
surpassed by of all things
solving a math problem which is
not an experience
anyone wants to give to users of
their site.
So you have the business that's
operating on tight margins to
begin with, needing to capture
every dollar it can.  You have
users who when they come to the
slow site are in need of the
serious zen.  How do we reduce
stress?
Meditation, massage, mindfulness
is great but may be difficult to
impart on shoppers of your site.
We can focus on what we can
actually control, improving the
overall performance UX and the
general experience ever visiting
any commerce
site to begin with.
Before we dive into that
though, we wanted to take a
moment to clear up the terms
involved.
Specifically, AMP and PA.  We
have seen confusion here.  Some
people have been thinking that
actually it is AMP versus PA.
That's actually understandable
both terms came about at the
same sort of time, they're both
web related and like Adam said,
we have thrown new stuff at you
all the time, it could be hard
to differentiate those.  Let's
clear it up.
It is not AMP versus PA, these
are not exclusive choices,
they're complimentary approaches
when developing for the web.  It
is not AMP versus PA, but AMP
and PA together.
Let's take a refresher on the
relationship then
.  Let's start with AMP or
accelerated mobile pages.  AMP
is an Open Source project that
began a few years ago to combat
performance issues on the web
and there are two aspects to
this.
First, AMP is a Library of
Components on HTML specifically
designed for performance.
Second, the AMP format mandates
a number of rules on pages that
are again focused on maintaining
performance but also on enabling
cashing and this
ability to cache and serve
remotely enables platforms
serving AMPs to rendser them
effectively.
If that's the technical aspect,
the
business benefit is this is 15
engineers looking at issues on
the site leaving your engineers
free to focus on the features
you're focused on.  The end
result, when you combine these,
AMP content loads for a user on
average average in a half
second.  An additional piece of
AMP to consider, some of the
architectural choices to make
when adopting the technology.
The most widely used pattern at
the moment creating a separate
page using
amp and linking it against the
HTML-page the same way you
maintain multiple translations.
At link versions, you are served
on Search, Twitter, Bing,
anything
platforms that link to the AMP
content.  This  allows you to
get in the platform and you have
two versions of the site
introducing extra overhead.
Like I said before, AMP is a
framework of components and if
you can use those components to
perform an effective webpage,
residents those the requirements
for your webpage any way.  If
AMP is working for you, an entry
point for some user, you may
want to think about using it as
a front end framework for all of
the users.  This approach is
gaining popularity in
a variety of sites that have
done it, including trip.
com which you see there, they
serve over 300 million users in
13 languages and they just
launched a new site that's
built entirely in AMP.
So if AMP is a concrete library
and
platform, you can think of PA as
the
overarching methodology behind
all of this.
Hopefully you have seen these
four pillars before.
I want to try to cement this in
your minuted now.  These are
things we really want you to
consider when you're developing
for the open web.  Fast is up
there, that's a goal that we
share with AMP, performance
really does need to be built in
from the start.
Next up, integrated.  Integrated
means a more app like experience
with the website.  It should
feel like it belongs on the
device.
That means it is open on window
or could have icons on the home
screen or desktop and reliable,
that means that you can give me
an intelligent experience
regardless of my network
connectivity state.
No more  browser error pages.
Finally, all of these build to
create engaging experiences.
That means notifications when I
need them, content that I can
trust just to display when I ask
for it.  All of that is wrapped
up in the UI
that feels familiar and at home
on my device.
So we have talked about what AMP
is and PA is, it is pattern to
note that several different
patterns exist for combining AMP
and PA or for just using one or
the other and we'll get into
that in a little bit.
To start, here is a classic user
journey funnel and we'll use amp
at the top in the acquisition
and browsing portion of a user's
journey and on PA on the bottom
of the funnel.  When a user
looks to convert and had when a
business is then aiming to build
them in a loyal customer through
retention and reengagement.
This is a bit of an over
simplification of the two
concepts.  What I want to give
you here, a way to frame these
ideas in terms of where the
strengths will give you the
bigger ROI.
In broad terms, AMP gives you
the easy development path for
fast sites, that strength will
will give you the most value at
the top of the funnel.  As you
progress through the funnel, the
user is no longer browsing.
They have made a decision.  The
priorities are evolving.   Here
you want the PA pillars of
integration and reliability to
ensure the conversion portion of
the funnel provides the best
experience possible so you can
build that one happy transaction
into a repeat customer.
Let's start with the first
step in any e-commerce journey.
Acquisition of a new user via
entry
points to the site we'll show
you what AMP looks like in
practice and success some sites
are seeing and we'll dive into
the tech you can use to
customize the pages.
What matters most at the
beginning, speed and
performance.  In this series it
will show why.
On the left is the non-AMP
version and on the right, you
have the AMP version.  When
properly implemented, the user
on the AMP page completes the
transaction before the non-AMP
user gets to fully view the
first page.  Why is speed so
important in this first
discovery phase?  It is this
point where you really
differentiate yourself and the
competition.  If I'm looking for
particular brand off camera, I'm
looking through a list of
suppliers all selling the same,
similar products.   If I tap on
one of the options, it doesn't
load immediately, I may not wait
around.  I'm probably just going
on to the next site.
The reality is, most sites are
not that fast.  If you have a
super fast site upon
load, it can make you stand out.
We have seen tons of sites do
this in the commerce space, we
have three examples from three
top sites from around the world,
we want to point out when we say
e-commerce here, we don't just
mean retail but travel and other
transactions and verticals as
well.
The fist, from a larger company
in Brazil, Magazine Luiza and we
have an example from price line,
global travel site serving 1.
5 million active daily users and
they just delivered AMP for many
sites and they're growing that
to other content as well.
Finally, we see an example from
flip
card, the India travel brand no
stranger to performance boosting
as they were the first site to
launch a PA.  When we talk about
entry points we want to make
sure people understand the point
of entry is not limited to
reflecteds from Google.  There
are over a dozen top platforms
that link to AMP pages.  The
fastest version of an AMP page
will load when a cache is
involved, whether it is or had
not, these mean a faster
experience for your content when
users find it.
Where a cache is involved, we
see this truly coming in play.
Google has a cache wherever they
link and this connect to AMPs
and the early results are
promising.  As you see here from
the experience of
the online retailer
, AMP pages are faster which
means increasedded conversions
and we're working on a beta to
bring the power to PLAs and
we're excited to announce that
two of the top landing page
providers,
ers, instApage and others are
doing this.
And others are Alpha testing
before rolling out completely.
As far as results overall, here
are some metrics that sites are
seeing.
Me e-commerce.
E-commerce merchants are
seeing increases in revenue
following the
deployment of AMP and Twitter is
seeing
decreased page load abandonment
and the express here, it is all
built in AMP so they're not
using the paired approach we
referenced a few minutes ago for
the mobile version of the
website they still have a had
separate desktop version and
given the strong implementation
and success they're seeing,
we'll use them as a reference
implementation in slides to
come.  .
Now that we have talked about
AMP leveraging speed, let's dive
into technology that allows you
to customize
your AMPs and bridge together a
together an AMP and PA.
>> Thank you.
We have created our fast entry
point, and that's  grabbed our
potential customer's interest.
There are a few more steps to
turn that into a purchase.  When
I land on a site, I don't come
with an exact product in mind.
I come with a problem that I
want to solve.  Maybe I'm
thinking it is time to replace
my old sofa or perhaps I'm
thinking of getting some shirts
that aren't just black or gray.
I'm  not.  If I was, what I
would need is a way of narrowing
down that wider selection
to the end product.
As mentioned, we'll look at Ali
and what they're doing.  Here
you see the filtering and
sorting, we see the dropdown
there that let's me sort by
price and we can see the
side-bar coming  outletting me
filter by color.  Let's see how
we can create some of these
components in AMP.  Starting
with filtering, you can see in
this simplified Example there
are two main components.  We
have got the list of products we
want to display at the bottom
and we have the controls to
filter them at the top.
Let's look at that AMP list
tag first.
The source attribute here is
specifying a JSON endpoint.
That first source attribute is
the default full list of
products.  The second source
attribute is in square brackets.
That's because we're using the
functionality of AMP bind here.
The brackets tell us that we
want to bind the value of the
list source variable to the
source attribute and that means
when list source changes,
we're going to update our list.
Now we need to provide UI to
allow the user to change that
variable.
Since AMP is still HTML we can
use the stand controls here.
You have the radio button to
toggle the color.  You can see
that I have populated the
on attribute, this is a
convention for creating an event
listener.  I'm listening for the
change event.  When I get there,
I'm going to update list source
to include yellow if the option
is checked.  That's it.  If the
color -- if I select color in
the form, that updates the
variable and the list will re.
Let's generalize that pattern.
What you do here, you set up the
list for a dynamic source and
then you add form controls to
update the source.  It is
simple.  It is flexible.
Hopefully to improve that, I'll
show you a couple of other
applications of this.
If be jump over to sorting them
we have the same lists on the
bottom and top.  The difference
here, instead of alternating the
path on the variable I had
before, I'm pulling out the
event value and dropping that
straight into the GET parameter.
Here if we want to add a new
option like sort by rating, then
all we have to do is support it
on our endpoint and then we just
add that option into the form
and it is going to work.
It is not just static controls
either.  We can use the same
functionality to take a value
that the user types and pass
that along to our back end.
You see here AirBnB
experimenting on this for
Autosuggest on destinations.
We'll look at this.  We're not
making use of the change event
here, users may be typing faster
than the service is returning
results.
Instead, we're making use of the
input debounced event and that
allows us to smooth that input
out a little bit.  Then you have
the familiar pattern.
You type the query, it is in the
GET parameter, we have the
results.
Finally then, the configuration
of that list isn't always based
on user
input, but actually user
context.
In this example from the aptly
named AMP by example.com we're
showing geo location.  Behind
the scenes we're doing a geoip
look up on the server.  It is
not precise location but general
user area.  This is perfect for
doing something like listing
nearby stores for product
collection.  The touch I like
here, it is the dummy items
beforehand so that we can see
something as the content is
loading.
Let's see how that is done.
The call goes to the server
and you use the placeholder
attribute.  At the bottom we're
using that to show that dummy
item.  When the request comes
back, we're repliesing that with
the populated template and to
the user it looks like a smooth
transition in.  Also, for a
bonus material, we
recently announced AMP geo
letting you do location at the
country level which is useful
for doing things like price
formatting or delivery options.
Okay.  We'll take a breather.
We made it through the first
stage of our funnel.  The one
thing we really want you to take
away from this section is that
speed is key for acquisition but
that doesn't mean you need to
sacrifice rich content as well.
That simple pathway can let you
combine the speedy display of
cached
content with Larrying in of
personalized -- layering in of
data.
>> Now we go and find the
product I want, we buy it.   The
steps I want to examine here
then, add to cart.  We'll stick
here and see how they built this
in-page experience with AMP.
First we're going to need a
structure to store the product
we want to add to the basket.
We have populated that with the
data we know already.  That's
the country  name, the price
formatting, the quantity, we
have the null placeholders which
are for the additional options
that we'll configure in the
page.
When these AMP fill in the
placeholders, when the user taps
on that size, we map that into
the data structure.  We also are
mapping it back to an element on
the screen so that the user
has visual feedback that
something has happened.
We'll use AMP bind to map the
product properties into the
hidden inputs of the add to cart
form.  Finally, the additional
ingredient
here, it is the action attribute
which
again is AMP convention for
allowing the in-page form
request.  Now when the response
comes back we can upgrade the
page and configure the message.
So we have done add to cart with
in-page interactions in AMP
setting a high bar for speed.
What happens when I make the
transition off of AMP?  If we
present the user with a slow
spinner, we're burning all of
that good will we built up in
the first stage.  Instead, while
we know we're making a
transition maybe from cache to
hosted, from AMP to the wider PA
world, we don't want the user to
know that.  We want it to feel
like a seamless consistent
progression.
Conveniently, that's a perfect
segue
for progressive web apps, a
service
worker can act like what caching
proxy service and that means we
can go ahead
and warm-up that cache before
the user gets there.
In our AMP content we make use
of the AMP tag to start this
process.  We're providing the
service worker location and a
frame on the domain because the
service worker can only be
installed from the domain.  When
the install starts, we're ready
to start prepping that content.
To show you a super simple base
here, and so in here, what we're
doing, we're doing the install
step, caching what I call the
site furniture, so that stuff
like your fonts, header images,
so on, and then we have a fetch
handler, when the user taps to
go to the new page, that kicks
in and starts to use the cache
content, this is a very tip of
what you can do so I highly
recommend checking out the work
box library to get
production patterns to make use
of here.
We focused a lot on the fast
pillar from our principle.
That's fine.  It is not the
whole story.  Caching solves
some of the problems for
browsing and not changes like
add to cart.  We don't want the
user dropping out of this
critical stage just because the
connection drops.  This was a
problem that one of the real
pioneers of the commerce on the
web
set out to solve.  EBay is the
online marketplace to find 1.1
billion listings and they sell
over $23 billion of transactions
just in the
first quarter of this year
alone.   Reliability is core to
that experience for them.  They
have been working to enable
their add to cart button to work
offline.  I really love this use
case.  It is not about trying to
make the entire site work
offline or do some crazy user
experience.  They picked a
critical part of their
user journey and focused on
making that reliable, solving a
real business problem.  That's
the key.
Don't think of offline and
online as
binary states but think of
robust independent add to cart,
that's not as catchy for putting
on a slide.
So really what happens here, oh
's   bay simplifies this
experience.  I press it, they
take care of the rest.
First, the default behavior, if
I tap add to cart and the
connection is 23409 there, the
request fails and drops out.
What do we need to do?
Instead, when that request
fails, we're going to capture
the details that we need to send
it again and save them.  When we
reconnect, we retrieve that
data, recreate our request and
send it.  Simple enough concept.
Let's dive into a little code.
First, let's go back to the
fetch handler again.
I'm intercepting the add to cart
requests.  Always be specific
when doing something like this.
You don't want unintended side
effects interfering with other
requests from the.
A.  Next, we fire off the
request.  If it succeeds, great,
we have nothing else to do.
However, if it fails, we want to
pull out the request details.  I
have cloned the request, the
body is read and you can only
reread it once.   I'm using the
local forage library to
give a simple key value store
and the current time stamp is my
key and I'm
saving the request body.  Now we
have saved the request, we want
the matching functionality to
retrieve that as well.   In this
function, back in my compliant
logic, I'm iterating through the
existing increase and using this
time stamp to filter out the
ones from the last ten minutes.
I don't want to randomly add
things to
the user cart hours later.
I'm using that save data to
just build a new post request
for the same add to cart action
and send it.   Finally, I have
attached this function to listen
for the online event in the
browser and that means when the
page registers online again it
will kick in and attempt to send
all of those requests.
You should also be hooking up in
other places as well such as
payload or service worker
application.  For bonus content
as well, look at the background
sync API for what you may be
able to do to assist in the
future.
Briefly then, because we have
worked hard to get the user this
far, we should probably take
some money from them.
That said, Adam and I have
already crammed too much content
in this talk.  We the want to
shout out to some of the other
talks that are doing this.  In
fact, directly after this, on
Stage 7 there is a Google pay
best practices
talk if you want to keep the
e-commerce theme going.
With that, we're on to the home
straight.  Let's look at what
the we can do after the sale to
try to turn this person into a
repeat customer.  To have repeat
customers, they'll need to have
a way of actually getting back
to us and add to home screen is
a way to do this.  It is super
easy to implement.  It is not
always relevant.  The home
screen is for daily quick
access and if you have an
airline, a furniture company,
success for you is not measured
in daily active users.
The purchase patterns are
seasonal or periodic.  What if
you can give me something
personal instead.  Let's say I
have ordered that new sofa, on
the order confirmation page you
can give me an option to track
the order.  When I tap that,
I'll be prompted to add the
order to my home screen.
Let's look at how to make that
happen.  On the confirmation
page we're linking to the
manifest.  In this case, it is
not a static file, it is a
dynamic resource.
We'll populate it with a custom
name, image, URL, so on.
We don't want to randomly
trigger this screen prompt, we
only want to do it in response
to the button.  This is
something to add on all of the
pages to ensure that you are
intercepting the app to home
screen event.  We capture the
before install event and prevent
it from showing and retrigger it
for the listener for the track
order button.
That's it.
Now I have it right there on
the home screen and it is not
the home page of the furniture
site but going to the current
status of my order.  The benefit
here, when my order is done you
can maybe just show me a message
saying it is fine for me to
delete the icon now or you can
show me additional products and
perhaps I should
get that matching coffee table
as well.
Any way, if you do this, you
need a way of measuring the
success and there are three
places to check.  First, let's
revisit where we're triggering
that prompt.  It is not
justifier and forget here.  We
can expand the result of the
prompt.  In this case I'm firing
a Google analytic event for the
install and dismissed events.
Next up, you can use the unique
location for your start URL that
will only be used by the
manifest.  Again, I just added
Google analytics campaign
parameters on the end of the
URL.
For the final signal we'll make
use of this display standalone
property and
that's what's causing the app to
launch in its own window without
the browser controls and turns
out that this can be
matched with the media query.
Here we're using match media to
detect standalone mode and
trigger
another analytic event.  This is
important because users may deep
link in the web app and they're
not triggering a launch from the
home screen.  There you go.
With these three signals, you
are now
measuring installs, launches,
usage for the app.
Since I mentioned other things
with the app, I want to end with
notifications, I'm not showing
code, that's the easy parted.
Potentially it is even too easy
because I keep hitting sites
that as soon as you land on the
domain ask you for the
notification permission.  This
is spammy behavior which hurts
the ecosystem.  When I say hurts
the ecosystem, I mean, it hurts
you as developers because we
start making it harder to use
these features.
I want to be able to get useful
push notifications, and to do
that, I need all of you to
really champion the best
practices here.
So I want you to make sure
that every notification you send
satisfies these three things,
who, it should be personal
information to me, my delivery
or a sale on an item I'm
watching.  Then what, as in
what's actually happened, if you
can give me everything I need
concisely in the notification I
may not even need to tap it.
When?  That means sending them
at appropriate times and
expiring them when no longer
needed.  What's that look like
when you pull it altogether?  It
looks like this.
It is personal to me, it gives
me enough information to act
without tapping, that 5-minutes
warning was worth interrupting
me.  If that's the case, I
better head over there so I can
relax on the new sofa and
I'll hand it back over to Adam.
>> Adam: Thank you.
Using the service worker and
building a PA means an uptick in
business metrics just like we
saw early earlier with AMP.  In
Starbucks for example, they
launched a PA last year and they
have seen the daily and monthly
active users in this format
double.  That's the full funnel
going from acquisition via super
fast entry pages using AMP to
converting and retaining users
via PA.   We have talked a lot
about how the technologies work
separately and we want to
highlight that they can work
together and there are different
patterns to do so.
After all, in the case of both
AMP and PA we're talking about
web pages.  The two technologies
are complimentary ways of
achieving different goals, each
with their own strengths and
challenges.
When they're combined, you enjoy
the benefits of both, AMP and PA
givens you a feature-rich
experience that stays and starts
fast.
The first example here, 1-800
flowers delivering flowers angus
to 150
countries around the globe
linking AMP pages serving as an
entry point in the site to a PA.
Within that PA they are
leveraging the Google sign on as
an identity solution and they're
allowing users to check out via
Google pay.
It is a great example of
utilizing AMP and PA together
but several pieces of the mobile
web toolkit and in early
testing, they showed 150%
conversion increase with the PA.
Shop clues, a
leader in India launched an app
in PA
last year and similar to 1-80
flowers, they're using this as
entry points and linking to a
PA.  The framework helped them
see an increase in conversions,
Roo reduction in load time and
reduction in bounce rate.
The pattern of linking to the
AMPs into a PA is not the only
solution.  There is another one
that's starting to emerge, you
use the two together in the same
document.  When a user visits
such a page through an AMP cache
they get the AMP page, when
continuing the journey on the
site origin they get the full
AMP and PA experience, including
the speed and turn key use of
AMP and extended capabilities of
PA.   The simplest first step to
do this is what we showed
earlier, just to add a
service workinger with basic
caching to an existing page.
With that, you can layer on
others as you like and that
includes push notifications,
advanced caching and offline
support and add to home screen
prompt.   Annual the alternate
pattern is to
use this for an AMP function
which is then function pages.
This can be a little more
complex and it may require a
little more work to make it
work.
We have seen some sites do so
including carve.com, an online
retailer making phone cases and
the global car brand BMW.  A
benefit from either pattern, on
top of speed and performance is
that they simply build on any
investment you made with AMP and
you use that work.
That's about it.  We have
learned a few things today.
How to start fast with the AMP
pages and stay fast with the PA.
You can successful
ly combine.  We have talked
about AMP pages and sending
notifications via the web to the
users.
We talked about service worker
and AMP custom library and
companies seeing success with
the formats and some seeing
success by combining the formats
together.  The bottom line is,
we know the web has amazing
reach and the tools now exist to
help ensure the capabilities
with and the web has engagement
and profitability as well.
Check out the documentation on
the
websites or stick around to ask
questions and we'll be here and
then be in the sandbox  later.
We can't wait to see what you
build.  Thank you.
How AMP Has Evolved Beyond Web
Pages
.
>> Good morning! How is
everyone doing?
(Vamsee  Jasti) and I'm a
software engineer.
We have a lot to cover.  Let's
go.
>> VAMSEE JASTI: The web used
to look like this, made up of
destinations that people
remembered and went to.
However, the web is
transitioning to a
post-destination era.
Users' browser plans changed on
the web because of social,
mobile and search
which means that users finding
content across all sorts of
devices and
platforms like aggregators, chat
apps, social websites and search
and many others.
With AMP we saw an opportunity
to help
developers have their
experiences and content
transition to this
post-destination era and today
we're going to tell you how.
For those of you that haven't
heard of AMP, it is an Open
Source web development framework
making it super easy to build
excellent web pages.  With AMP
it is hard to make web pages
that are slow, not impossible
but hard.  When we launched AMP
we want to ensure that
developers have full control
over the brand so we provide
support for
custom CSS and we want to ensure
that AMP developers are able to
make revenue
off of these AMP pages and we
provided support and robust
paywall support.
Since its launch, more than 3
years ago, AMP is fully
transitioned from a platform
that was mostly meant for static
web pages to one that gives
developers flexibility to build
interactive dynamic experiences.
Developers can build pages with
wish lists, interactive product
customizations, filtering,
sorting, you name it.
Therefore, a number of
e-commerce
publishers including the one
here from AliExpress are
transitioning the entire sites
to AMP.
Adding all of this new
capability, the AMP teamworks
really hard to ensure that the
performance of the page and
sites remain still great.
For example, the speed of an AMP
page is less than a second from
the search corpus.  This talk is
not about performance.
This talk is about how AMP can
help
you content and experience
creators build for the
post-destination era.  How do
you do that?
You ensure that the content and
experiences work
well when embedded in
aggregators.
AMP was built for embeddablety
since day one.
Fun fact, before it was called
AMP it was PCUs or portable
content units which
were supposed to be widgets that
lived everywhere on the web.
Spoiler alert, we think you
should build your experiences
with AMP because the principles
that AMP is built on top of
lends itself really well for
embeddablety.  Before we look at
the principles, I would like to
give a preview on the products
AMP has fueled that were
previously not possible in the
context of embeddablety.   With
AMP for email, we'll see how AMP
is fundamentally changing email
to make
it more realtime and dynamic.
No more leaving email to get
things done.
With AMP HTML ads we'll show you
how everything is more secure
and performing.
With actions we'll show you how
AMP is helping getting things
done on the web with a few taps.
With zero-click AMP we can see
how to get to content for users
before they even ask for it.
Yes.  Yes!  We'll see how AMP is
going to help users get to
things even before they ask for
it.  Last, one more thing,
regrettably, you'll have --
you'll wait until the end to
find out about it.
Now I would like to invite you
to tell
us about the principles beyond
why AMP
is great and a good fit for
post-destination experiences.
>> Thank you.
Before we look at the AMP
principles
we should look at issues the
wait this works on the web
today, from there we'll get a
better understanding of why AMP
is
great for embeddablety.
Current technologies like i
frames and web views have three
major issues,
they're not performance perform
plant, secure or functional.
Let's look at them one by one.
First, performance, there is no
guarantee that embedded page
would be perform performant so a
host is likely to have the
embedded content to create a
faster user experience since
Java script is -- not it mention
the privacy
of making user data in this
scenarios.
Next, embedded page may bring
security issues to the host.  We
know that scripts bringsor
brings all kinds of security
hosts, even if
properly sandboxed within i
frame
unknown Java script can install
malware
or bit coins without user
permission in the background.
Technologies like feature policy
may
be able to solve this by
allowing the host to selectively
enable and disable
uses of various process features
and APIs but unfortunately it is
not available today.
Of course, a page can cling to
the host that it is safe to
embed.
There is no way to guarantee
that.
Finally, since there is no
communication between the host
and the
embedded page, the host has to
treat it as a black box veerly
restricting
product experience that builds
with
communications built on a
standardized protocol.  As shown
here, the embedded page will
not be able to know when you
have user
not even with the native
observer API supported because
it is sandboxing across the
domain i  frame.
Because of this, basic features
like video autoplay or
viewablety tracking are not
available.
We have briefly talked about the
concerns and issues with the
embedded technologies today.
With that in mind, let's now
take a look at the AMP principle
that provides excellent support
to embeddablety and
why many hosts have chosen AMP
as the technology for
embeddablety.  We'll cover the
principles in three parts and
the first is  privacy-preserved
prerenderring.
That's a tongue twister.
Apart from the performance
benefit to
you by using the AMP library,
host can further optimize and
provide instant
loading experience by
prerenderring AMP documents.
Prerendering here is referring
to the
host downloading and rendering
documents
before a user explicitly
expressed their intent.  As you
see from the demo here, instant
loading is clearly experiencing
what the user will love.
Despite a great user experience
that prerenderring provides you,
it ends up using a lot of
bandwidth and CPU.  That's the
reason why host won't just
normally go ahead and prerender
many
embedded documents.  Documents
on the other hand are
optimized to only render
light-weighted resources that is
above the folder.  Let's take a
look at the code here.
Here you will find AMP will
calculate
a prerender rectangle and will
only load
resources within the rectangle
and it will be the first view
port.  This can be over ridden
by the host to
customize the size based on real
product needs.  Next you will
find apart from the
first port restrictions and also
delays loading of happy weighted
resources in
terms of CPU after the-page is
visible.  The fact that AMP
documents only rendered
light-weighted resources that
are above the folder that help
to
minimize the usage of CPU and
bandwidth
allowing the host to prerender
the AMP HTML documents more
aggressively compared to regular
HTML documents.
Because of this, there's a much
higher chance that instant
loading experience is delivered
and the user can see the
content the moment they want it.
I believe some of the
audiences have
noticed a big challenge with
prerenderring, and that's how to
protect user data -- user
privacy.  If this is unclear to
you, I would like to explain the
issue behind.
Prerendering requires
downloading the document before
user clicks, otherwise instant
loading is not possible
especially on mobile  devices.
This means that the owner of the
page that's been prefetched may
be able to
set a cookie and then later on
target your ad based on that
cookie even though you never
ended up on that page.
Apart from that, rendering
documents beforehand makes it
possible to fire
tracking Pixel before the page
view.
Luckily AMP documents counts
what
privacy preserved prerenderring
support built in from day one.
To protect user privacy,
trackers and
analytics must be delayed until
the user has explicitly
expressed their intent to
see the document, AMP controls
this with a a centralized
resource manager and
this manager blocks all
components and services that
make external requests before
page view.
For example, the AMP Pixel and
AMP
analytic component are blocked.
The AMP cache adds additional
privacy protection on top of
that as mentioned
before, AMP cache is an
important part
of the AMP ecosystem, it is the
proxy based account delivery
network for delivering valid
documents only.  One of its
major purpose is to allowing AMP
documents to be preloaded
efficiently and safely.  With
prefetch requests going to the
AMP cache, page owner won't be
aware of the requests and then
won't be able to
set cookies before user
expressed their interests.
We have talked about security,
we have talked about privacy,
next let's talk about security
and why host can safely embed
AMP pages.  There are two ways
to think of security.
One, from the perspective of the
embedded page, and the other one
from the content that's trying
to embed content.  We'll be
focusing on another one
today, after all if a page isn't
guaranteed to be safe, the host
won't embed it.  So what's the
mechanism here that
makes a host to be able to trust
an embedded AMP page.
May I present you the AMP
validator.  The AMP validator
makes it possible
for a host to verify that an
embedded page is guaranteed AMP
and has no security
vulnerabilities.
Here is an example of the online
version of the AMP validator
tool.
This tool creates a common
agreement that both the content
creator and host
can both agree upon for secure
embedding.  Problem solved,
right?
Well, not  exactly.  Realtime
validation can be very expensive
and not practical.  The host
made a better way to verify
the validity of an AMP document
much faster.  Cache provides the
answer here.  The host can
deliver documents from the AMP
cache without realtime
validation since AMP cache will
only
extract valid documents.
This is the end of the story
if AMP is
only designed for fully-formed
web pages, but with these
features and capabilities, AMP
can be used to work
across multiple contacts and
with each
individual context AMP supports
a unique spec and validator.
For example, there is a
different spec
for AMP HTML ads versus AMP
HTML.  We need to do this
because, for
example, the AMP i frame
components, it
is not allowed as part of an ad
because
it could embed  non-content in
the ad and will use the
performance guarantees.
From the two validation examples
here you can find that the same
set of HTML results in different
validation status
when different spec is being
applied.  Last, let's talk about
the interface between the host
and the embed and the two-way
communication protocol that
helps to solve a number of
issues.  I want to introduce
this with an example.  Let's
look at this graph.  Say I want
a product like this.  If I go
search for pandas, I get all
of the related articles in one
place.
This requires the host to embed
a number of AMP documents and
place each
of them inside a full- screen i
frame.  What is the problem
here?
We know that the i frame will
consume
all user interactions so how
would a
user still swipe around and
navigate between different
documents.  With AMP, this is
possible.
Let's dive deeper with some
code.
Here you will find AMP documents
will
propagate all end use events and
send the event to the host.
The host can then handle this
touch event as if it is native
touch event from the browser,
this enables user to navigate
between different documents.
Conversely, the host can inform
this ability change event back
to the AMP
documents through the visibility
chain message.
When an AMP document is
informed, that it is visible to
user, it can then
trigger page view Pixel or start
loading
resources that's below the
folder.
The communication interface API,
it is
Open Sourced and well
documented, and supports two-way
communication like
this, the host and the AMP
documents, they can together
bring a much better user
experience.  For example, this
is a real product that Google is
able to build based on
this communication protocol.
With these principles keep in
mind,
let's walk through some exciting
products that Google builds
using AMP.
Thank you.
>> VAMSEE JASTI: Thank you.
There you have it, the
principles behind why AMP is
great for embeddablety.  As
promised, let's shift gears back
to looking at some of the
embedded product features that
AMP made possible.  The first
product I want to talk about,
email.  Little has changed in
the email spec over the past 25
years, it is a wonderful piece
of technology that allows --
that's critical for how people
communicate with other people,
businesses, tools, services.  If
you're an email sender there is
little that the email receiver
can do other than retrieve the
email as a notification.  Email
is not actionable today.  The
web is much more dynamic than
this, as you know.
This type of realtime on the
web, it is provided to you by
Java script and that's not
allowed within email because of
security reasons.
To tackle this, the G email
teamworked
with the team to open an AMP for
email
making email richer and more
powerful it is a subset
particularly focused on
security.
It is also important to note
that there is an easy transition
path from the way that email
works today.  Email senders
already create two
versions of the email, one a
plain text
version and second, an HTML
version.  Senders can now create
an optional third version, the
AMP version.  This allows
senders to design their AMP part
of the emails independent of the
HTML versions.
So if a provider supports AMP
for email, they'll render that
AMP version.  If not, the mail
proker changes nothing and shows
the HTML version of the email.
Why don't we dig into the spec
a bit.  The realtime nature of
the spec is
enabled by an AMP component, AMP
list, which allows email authors
to fetch realtime information
from an endpoint.  For example,
nobody wants to see outdated
prices of products in emails.
AMP allows authors to fetch
realtime content on their emails
right before the
user is about to open the email.
The interactive nature of the
spec is
brought to you about I component
called bind allowing interactive
experiences
for email using rich JSON
expressions.  This allows you to
be able to respond back to an
invite with a single click.
We'll look at examples in
action.
The first, it is from Zillo's
whose goal is to help shoppers
find the dream home which is
easier if shoppers tell them
what exactly they're looking
for.  With AMP for email, a
shopper can get from answering a
few questions to personalized
search results without ever
leaving their  email.
Let's roll the video, please.
Here we are, a received an email
and you can see how I answer the
questions right in line.
I can pick a minimum and
maximized price of a house, not
buying in the Bay area.  The
number of bedrooms I'm
interested in.
The type of home I want to look
for
and yes I want to get
notified and when I'm done I can
ask to see a personalized list
of houses too, I can browse,
look at images and save them
for viewing later all without
having to leave email.  It
returns email from a
notification
to an application.  The next
example I want to show you, it
is from pinterest.
Let's roll the video, please.
Somebody back there is
scrambling right now.  This
looks great.  You received an
email from pinterest, looking
very much like the emails you
have seen, gorgeous images.   As
you notice, regular email when
you click on it, it sends out
the pictures, you probably have
to log in.  This is AMP for
email, you can click and view
the recipe right there.
Look at photos, comments, and if
you're not interested, you can
go back to the feed, this is all
in email.  You can check out a
different recipe, chicken taco
sounds nice.   I'll save that
and pin it to my
dinner board right within email.
This is great for users because
they're able to discover new
things from right within email
and great for pinterest, this
allows pinterest to deliver a
much better experience to their
end users.  It is no
exaggeration that AMP is
bringing a new era of email
if you're a provider, we would
love to
help you with hub and if you
have the access, you can sign up
on the links on the slide.
Second product I want to talk
about, ads.  Ads are a thing
that gets embedded most number
of times than anything else in
the world.  Aside from the way
ads are implemented these days
it is a wonderful piece of
technology allowing the ad
creator
content to flow across the
entire web while embedded inside
of hosts.
Here is the problem:  With ads,
when it comes to performance,
there is miss aligned
incentives.  If the ad creator
is not careful, they impact the
performance of the page and bad
behavior for an ad is not
necessarily impacting the
creator but impacting the host
and therefore most
likely ends up resolving in a
bad user experience.
We want to fix that.
We created AMP HTML ads.  The
way this is implemented, they're
guaranteed to be fast, secure,
performing.  AMP HTML ads are
written in HTML
entirely which means they can't
have JS and they're verified
before delivered to a webpage.
I won't go into all the details
about
validation and all but I'll
leave a few links in the slides
so you can follow-up later.
Also these ads are supposed to
work on both AMP pages and
non-AMP pages and support for
mobile apps is coming soon as
well.  Let's take a look at what
a simple HTML ad looks like.
You include the top level tag
and then
you include the ad-specific
timeframe, a thinner version of
the main frame, and
finally, you wrap a simple AMP
image tab with an anchor link.
That's it, you have a simple ad.
That's just simple, right?
Can you build timeline-based
crazy AMP HTML ads?  You can.
We're taking is one step further
and partnering with tools,
tooling companies here.
I'm very happy to announce a
partnership with the Adobe
Anime team, a popular tool.  The
power of a tool like this, it is
it allows you to do time license
line based animation ads rather
than having
to manually hard clip them in
Java script.  The issue of
creating complicated ads, it
takes forever to get the
positionallinging, the layering
of the assets right but the end
results endses
up not being performing as well.
We have a quick demo on how easy
it is to perform great looking
ads that are performing.
Let's switch to the laptop,
please.
Cool.  If you haven't used this,
it is straightforward.
They do a really good job with
laying things out.  This is the
timeline scrubber, the most
important part.  We copied some
assets into here so I don't have
to start from scratch.   This
overall gives me the ability to
kind of position things and
layer things and this looks good
to me.
I'll go ahead and publish this.
We'll see how this looks.
That's a complicated ad and it
looks great.  Wait, there is a
Google thing appearing just way
before the make Google do it
part.  Let's fix that.
Let's see how easy it is to go
back and try to fix that.  Here
is the Google part.   I have
spotted the key frame.
I'll move the key frame out to
somewhere between the make and
the do it part.
I'm going to publish that again.
Let's go back.  Refresh it.
Let's see if it appears in order
now, make Google do it.  Yes!
Looking great.
Of course, I want to make sure
-- don't save it.
It is actually Ava lid AMP?
It is valid AMP, thinner
runtime.
It uses the AMP automated
extension which is a wraparound
the API.  I'll prove that it is
valid and copy that and plop
that in the validator and,
yes, that's passing too.
So we can switch back to the
slides, please.
That was entirely created in
an AMP
HTML without a had need for Java
script and I hope you agree
that's a complicated ad.
If I can do it, anyone can do
that.
So some publishers are already
choosing to use AMP HTML ads in
the ad campaigns they ex
compute.
execute and this company, they
had 90% lacy reduction and 32%
click through rate.  We think
this can help you achieve
business needs and also while
ensuring
that ads are fast, performing,
secure on the web.
You can learn more about AMP
HTML ads on the link on the
slide.
The next one, I want to talk
about, it is actions.
It is way too hard to get things
done on the web.  Especially
things involving a credit card.
The beauty of the web is in the
diversity of the merchants that
can fulfill the user's needs.
For a user that discovers a
merchant from  Google.com, the
user needs to reintroduce
themselves to the merchant with
things
like credit card information,
identity, this creates friction.
For example, 54% of users
abandon account registration
flows when you show them a
registration form.
33% abandon purchase flows when
you -- when you show the credit
card entry stage.  Nobody likes
to fill out a form.  Especially
on mobile.
So to solve this problem, the
action team at Google worked
with a few merchants to provide
a seamless transaction
experience with AMP pages,
Google sign-in and sessions
starting from the Google
assistants and Google search.
AMPs tight security performance
and communication APIs allow
Google to offer transaction
primitives such as identity,
payments and receipts as one
integrated package.   Actions
can also integrate with other
Google services in the future.
For example, say I want to make
a reservation for lunch this
afternoon.  Actions can actually
start to overlay
my Google calendar with my
permission on top of my booking
flow reservation flow without
ever having to share the entire
calendar with the merchant
making such   Guarantees on
non-AMP pages is really, really
hard.
Let's look at a few demos.
The first one, it is from an
entire check out experience in
AMP using actions.  Let's switch
to my phone, please.
I have been busy, I haven't
watched avengers yet, I'll try
to book tickets for avengers.
Avengers show times.
Live casting, what goes wrong?
4:00 p.m., they have a fast
checkout option with
the AMP logo, I'll click that,
see what happens.
That looks instantly and with
this, it is a realtime seat map
so I'll select
two seats to go with my wife and
you notice Google has filled in
all of my information, the
summary looks  great, I'll
complete purchase.  There.
I have my tickets in in in my
hand,
from deciding to go to the
movie, tickets in hand, less
than 30 seconds, not only that,
if I have to go back and find
it, it is on my Google account.
Not only  that, with a single
tap I
can share my email address with
Fandango if I choose to to get
offers and such.  Sure.   That's
it!
Now I'm a fandango VIP.
We can switch back to the
slides please.  Note I never had
to pick out a form
field, type in the email, credit
card information.  AMC is also
building an experience using
AMPs.
Next, let's look at doordash
making it really easy to order
food using AMP pages and actions
from the assistants.
Let's roll the video, please.
I'll let you say never too late,
never too early to order Italian
food.  I did that.
They have the AMP logo, I'll tap
on
that, great to get Margarita
pizza, a
good idea, I like roasted
garlic, and
I'll go ahead and add that to
the order.  Never not get
dessert.  I'll add that to the
order.  These are all AMP pages
by the way.  Then a view card.
You check out.  Google has
filled out all of the
information that I care about.
I don't have to ever enter a
credit card form or field.  I'll
go ahead, place the order.
That's it!
Getting things done using AMP
and actions with just a few
taps.  We can switch back to the
slides, please.
So it is a window situation for
users and merchants.   Users get
a fast checkout experience
that's Google  optimized.
Pages are written in AMP,
chances are they're performing
and they have a great user
experience.  Users almost never
need to fill out a credit card
form or enter any forms for that
matter.  There is a single place
for all your receipts in case
you want to track where the
order is, track the expenses in
general.  Merchants are able to
retain full control of the UI
with the AMP pages.  They can
build long-term relationships
with the customers and acquire
them over the long term.
Merchants get higher conversion
rates
because of the streamline
checkout experiences.  We have
seen greater than 20% sign in
and greater than 2 it X
conversion up
lift when using Google pay.
Merchants spend less time
implementing transaction
primitives and they add unique
value.  Stay tuned to hear more
details on this from the Google
team later this summer.
All right folks.  The last
product I want to talk  about.
It is how AMP is enabling some
powerful new  features, features
we're calling zero-click
experiences.  It means that in a
developer has pretty good
confidence on the thing that the
user is going to click next, why
not have it ready even before
they ask for it.  Let's look at
one such example.
Google images is building
frictionless visual search that
helps users go beyond the image
to your site.  Here is the
problem.  An average webpage
takes more than 15 seconds to
load and more than half of them
leave if the page takes more
than 3 seconds to load.  What if
we redies the cost of a click
down to 00 -- reduce the cost of
a click down to 0.
This is possible with the
privacy prerenderring.  This is
a way that the team is planning
to solve this problem with  AMP.
Let's say that I'm in the market
foreign straight -- market for
renovating my kitchen.
I go to Google images and search
ideas.  Now, that's when I
search for kitchen ideas.   I
find an image that's interesting
for me.  I click on it.
With AMPs privacy prerenderring,
you can prerender the webpage,
see where it is from and make it
readily available for the user
where you see that in the bottom
there.  If the user taps on the
preview, it loads instantly.
When users internalize the cost
of the click, it is down to
zero, it helps them explore the
rich content beyond the image.
Ultimately it is great for the
user because they're able to get
inspired and look at multiple
ideas on the web and it is great
for publishers because they
receive more traffic.
That was four different
products.  They are all using
AMP to implement the product
features not possible before.
Now to reveal the mystery,
right.  It is not so much an
example but a different way to
think about AMP.
We call it AMP as foundation.
It means that no matter the
content or the experiences,
where they live, you
can power the experiences using
AMP, including your own
destination sites.   Let's dig
into what an existing setup for
most publishers looks like.
A lot of publishers have
prepared AMP
pages that are across various
platforms as on the slide.
The way they know this is AMP is
following the link to HTML tag
on their non-AMP pages.  If you
haven't already produced AMP
pages, I hope today we have
enough reasons why you should.
So separately, a number of
publishers
also are building -- rebuilding
websites
with PAs or progessive web apps
to take advantage of things like
push
notifications, offline
capabilities and amazing things
you have heard about.  Where
does AMP fit in?  You know how
we talked about AMP being
excellence for embeddablety, you
take those same AMP pages and
embed them
inside of the PA.
You can use this with shadow dom
and you have the features in the
shell and
have the ad content layer
independent of that shell.
This works great overall and we
have some things that we're
continuing to fix.  We have to
call it out on the link on the
slide.
There was a super compelling
experience built with the
pattern we're
talking about and they also won
two awards so congratulations.
I would like to show you a video
showing the site they built for
BMW.com by embedding the pages
inside of PWAs.  Let's roll the
video, please.
>> How do you excite people
for a car brand who are not
interested in cars at all?
By listening to their needs and
telling them stories they
actually want to hear.
Data driven, entertaining,
helpful.  For this purpose, we
have developed a
central stage, a new home for
the BMW
brand, the all-new BMW.com.  For
a Web Ex importance just as
dynamic as the cars, we used
Google's high-speed AMP
framework and dramatically
increased performance and thanks
to another web technology called
PWA ultrasmooth full screen
videos and the next great story,
it is only a swipe away.
The result, a 30% higher click
through rate from Google search
and up to 3
times faster website loading
compared to competitors.  A
high-performance experience that
you
would only expect from a native
app,
and, of course, the configurator
or a local test drive are always
only one click away.  The all
new  BMW.
com, the world's fastest
automotive
marketing website.
>> VAMSEE JASTI: They have
done a great job with it.   The
site is live, you can go play
with it if you like.
Today we saw use cases where AMP
is the core layer that powers
them.  There are other things
we're not
thinking about, future use cases
in AMP
in car dashboard, Virtual
Reality, it is really yours to
explore.  If you take away one
thing today, it is this, the web
is moving towards a
post-destination era and if
you're a developer building
content or
experiences in the new era you
need to build on a technology
working everywhere, not just at
your  destinations.  AMP
delivers superior performance,
security and standards enabling
features
that are just not possible with
regular pages.  We can't wait to
see what you build with it.
Thank you.
UX and APIs that Developers and
Users
Love
eye
UX and APIs that Developers and
Users
Love
.
>> DAVID EAST: Hello,
everyone!
So the first rule when you come
to a talk is make sure you're at
the right talk.  I have done
that before!
This is UX and APIs -- UX and
APIs that Developers and Users
Love.  I'm David east.
I'm a developer advocate here at
Firebase.
It is kind of funny that I'm
giving this talk.  It wasn't all
that long ago that my
idea of user experience was just
completely wrong.  At Google we
have lots of talented,
motivating people that work on
user experience.
We have UX researchers, UX
designers, UX engineers and I
get to work with these people on
a lot of different occasions.
Usually at the beginning of a
project we'll have a UX designer
come and they'll make a mock.
I look at the mock and say, wow,
this is pretty.  They look at me
and without fail they
say I don't make things look
pretty, I make them work well.
This is my idea of user
experience, it started to
change.
I wondered if what if user
experience
is not just about the different
shades of blue.  I'm a
developer, I build applications
and think of things like this.
I see the app as a series of
views,
network requests, threats and my
friends
that work in UX, they tell me
this is
fine for your own mental model,
but the user, they see things
differently, they don't care
about the code that happens
behind the screen.  Everything
for your user is a moment.
Whether they're creating an
account for the first time,
making a payment,
writing the first post, each of
these
things is a moment.  The
important thing to understand
about moments, every single
moment comes with an
expectation.
We expect to be able to create
an account without seeing a
dozen red Boxes of information
we need to fill out.  We expect
to make a payment without it
being painful.
We want to write the first line
with confidence.
If we don't get this right, we
can give the user a  one-star
moment.
If we understand their
expectation, we can give them
what they need and give
them a five-star moment.
In order to understand what our
user needs, we have to not just
look at the applications as a
bunch of code, but we need to
think about our apps as a series
of moments.
I'm not here today to teach you
how to turn every single part of
your app into a five-star moment
bowl because I don't know how to
do that!
-- mostly because I don't know
how to do that.  I can help you
look at critical parts
of common applications and see
how to increase those moments.
I have been working on Firebase
for over four years now and I
have given a
lot of talks, how to use the
Firebase
hosting, how to structure the
data and
these are all very developer
focused talks.
If you think why we want fast
sites, why we structure the data
in a certain way, we don't do it
to feel good about ourselves --
maybe a little bit.  We do it
for the user.
Maybe Firebase isn't just a
development tool because we can
use it
to make a -- make moments for
the user better and it also
means we can look at
Firebase as a UX tool.  The
first moment I want to talk
about is onboarding.
To me, onboarding is really
interesting.  It is the first
impression the user
will have of the app and this is
a chance we can show them that
they're going to have a great
experience, and that's not
always what happens.  We don't
think about user's perspective
of onboarding.  You can get it
wrong.
At this point, you have the
users' interests, they're
excited, they downloaded the
asp, they opened it, they're
ready to see the content and
just use it.
We show them a wall.
In order to keep this
excitement, we need to onboard
them as quickly as
possible into reduced friction.
In order to do this, we're going
to have a lot of different
features, we'll have to allow
them to log in with multiple
different types of providers.
We'll have to show them that
they can easily reset the
password and we also want them
to link different accounts
because we don't want them
logging in with one provider and
coming back in, logging in with
another and wonder why they have
two different accounts.   This
is something that Firebase
authentication does.
There is multiple types of
authentication with Google,
Facebook, Twitter
, github.
Rather than a a option like
this, they may feel backed in
the corner, they say this is a
one-star moment and they bounce.
So instead, we can give them
multiple options, log in with
Google, sign in with email, even
your phone number or
just browse as a guest.
The problem here, is that one of
the most friction-filled Parts
ever creating an app is having
to I think of a password.   The
user wants to log in with email
and a password, not only is the
law of friction opening up the
keyboard, entering the email,
entering the password, the user
has to create the password in
the head, know that they're
basically going to forget it and
then
have to reset it sometimes in
the future.   What would be
great, if we can log in a user
without a password, what if we
take their email and have them
create an account.
Recently we released a new
feature called passwordless
authentication.  We'll how this
works.
User enters the email, send
link,
they then go and check their
email.  They get an email from
the app and it
comes with a sign in link so
they tap it
and it redirects them to the app
and it automatically signs them
in.  This is a great moment for
the user
because it is a less step, a
less password they have to enter
and we can
get them in the app much faster.
This feature is available on
Android, iOS and the web.   This
is a code sample of the website.
This is a Firebase instance and
we call the method, send sign in
link to
email, which takes in the user's
email
and then action code  settings,
some configuration.
This is asyncness so we await it
and set it to local storage
because we need that email
later.  At this point, we can
prompt the user,
may, check your email.
At this point, we see if they're
coming
in with this sign in link and we
can do that with help or method
from Firebase
authentication, we call it the
sign in link and if it is a
link, we are going
to get that email that we saved
to local storage.
I want to make sure that this
link is here if it is not, we'll
prompt them
again to make sure that we have
it because something could have
erased it from local storage, an
error could happen.  We prompt
them again to make sure we have
it.
We pass in the email and the
link and after that point, we
clean up after ourselves because
the user is logged in.
In order to provide it better
onboarding we have to give
multiple options so that they
feel more trust
when they log in and we reduce
the friction and not try to pull
too much from upfront.
Another moment to talk about
what happens when the app
crashes, the user is logged in,
on boarded quickly, the next
thing you know, the app crashes.
You may think that this is a
one-star moment.
This is a point in the app where
we show the user that we're
humans and that we
do make mistakes but we work to
fix them.
In order to fix things, we have
to know where the app is
breaking and we have to properly
monitor it.
This is something that crash
lytics does well.   Once you
have this, you have a dashboard
full of useful information and
you see the statistics which
makes you
feel good about your app but
when issues
occur we can see in which file
the issue occurredded in which
line of the code and how many
times it happened and for how
many users.
When a new issue, you have a
Cloud function trigger and you
can do something with this
information.
This this case we create the
name and then we have a new
trigger.
We get the issue information and
from here, I can do whatever I
want.   I can send this
information to slack so I get a
notification that we're having
an error.
I can maybe send it to a Twitter
status, hey, we have a problem
but we're working on it.
It is okay when we fail.  When
you do fail, it is a way to show
the user that we all are human
and trying to fix things and it
is a way to
earn trust in the users even
though
this gives insight into the
obvious one-star moments, you
have the crashes and it is clear
that this is not a great moment
for the user.
What about the ones that lurk
and we don't know about them?
This is usually
performance-based.
We may work on fast computers
and we may see fast connections,
but the users,
that's not always the case for
them.
We're not seeing the same
results as they are.
In this case, it is loading,
loading, loading, man!  There
you have it!
For the user, these slow loads
are really stressful, they're
sitting there
waiting for the data to come
back.
The problem is, we don't see
this as active but the users do,
how do we know these things are
happening, they're not happening
to us.
This is the case for Firebase
performance monitoring.
It allows us to set up tracing
in our
app and see real world data from
our users.  Once you have it set
up, you have all of the
information in the dashboard.  I
see traces by frequency and I
can
see the network response latency
from different countries.
Something I noticed in this, I
have one trace that is taking
almost 7 seconds to finish.
So I go, I inspect the network
requests happening in the app.
I notice I have the one that
takes about 2.
15 seconds to complete so I
drill in, I
see that this is actually a
cloud
function and it takes anywhere
between 2
seconds to almost 5 seconds to
complete.  Why is this
happening?  Well, this is my
fault.  I was really excited, I
was using a
new feature from Cloud functions
called Callable functions.
The way they work, it is that we
get a
function name and then we can
create a new callable function.
The callable function takes in
two arguments, data, which is
the data that
the function is called with by
the user or client and content.
Context, it is useful.
If the user is authenticated, we
will
get their ID, other information
about the user.  Now that I have
the ID, I can go out,
get some databased on it.
Callable functions, they don't
stop on the server side but
there is a client
SDK for Android, iOS and the
web.  In this example, I'll call
a  callable function by the
function name and I can call it
with any data I need and then
inside of the call back I can
bind that
result to a view.
Why is this slow?  This is a
mistake I was making.
I had to get all of this data to
the view, I was making three
sequential network calls.  This
one could take anywhere between
a half second to two seconds and
then I would make this one,
another half
second, two seconds, and then
yet again, you could see
sometimes this will take
almost 7 seconds.  I decided to
trace this and fix it so
I create a custom trace and
start it.
Then I aggregated the three
calls into one on the server
side so now rather than waiting
for three calls I'm waiting for
one.
This might be a little faster,
but it is still about a half
second to two seconds which I
wouldn't call that
really a 5-star moment, kind of
a 3-star moment and the reason
why, the reason
why it takes this long, your
user may be
somewhere else on the other side
of the world than where the
server is located.
The user is on the slow network,
it
occurs latency getting to the
server and back.  This is
something that you can solve
with Firebase hosting.
Traditionally, you may think
Firebase
hosting as just the way to serve
websites.  When you think
outside of the box, you can use
Cloud functions and Firebase
hosting together to create
really fast rest APIs.  Because
with Firebase hosting, it is
backed by a content delivery
network which means that we have
an entire network of  servers
all around the world so that
when the user needs a piece of
data, they're not traveling
across the
world, they're going right up
the street.
The server code for this, I
swish from using a callable
function to an on
request function to control the
response.
So I set a cache control header
and it tells the server how long
we'll cache
this on the network, and then I
can
decode the token with the
fire-businessed admin SDK and
now the Firebase hosting then
talks to Cloud functions.  I set
up this configuration file where
I just set up a server rewrite
and I say
whenever you see this path call
this Cloud function.  I write
Firebase deploy from the command
line.
The rest API is available to the
world for use.  I  refactorred
the app and I just now call -- I
make a network request out to
the domain, I wondered just how
fast is this now.  I waited a
day, and I went back to the
dashboard.
I filtered within the last 24
hours and I saw that my network
requests went
from almost 7 seconds down to 68
milliseconds.
That's how fast it loads from a
cold start the app -- with a
cold start of the app, the data
load, it feels almost instant.
This is what the user expects.
They expect to load the app and
see
the data immediately.
In order to give a user great
moments we need to be able to
monitor real performance, not
just worry about -- not just
look at the performance we see
when we develop but the
performance that
happens in the wild.
Now my favorite moments is
handling offline situations.
When your user loves the app,
they'll bring it everywhere with
them.  They bring it camping,
they take it on the  plane.
They bring it to their friend's
house that has bad cellular
service and really flakey wi-fi
and despite these
circumstances, we still want to
give the user a great moment
even when we don't have the
connection.
That's not really what happens
in a lot of the apps we build or
download.  We want to use it,
don't have the
connection, we have a UI saying
sorry,
find a connection, use this app
later.
This isn't what the user is
looking for.  The user
downloaded the app to use it to
view the content and if we're
not able to provide them with an
offline
experience it is a disappointing
moment and we don't want to just
build read only apps offline, we
want them to be functional, we
want to provide as much
experience without a connection
as we can with a connection.
The problem with doing this, it
is when we build the apps, we
have to split everything up when
it comes to data retrievable.
We'll have an offline cache of
data for when the user is
offline and then
back online, we make network
requests
and
sync that with an offline cache.
It is difficult to architect in
your app and online, you think
about it on the offline stage,
online, easy to create bugs and
easy to get confused.
This is my favorite part of
using cloud fire store.
The cloud firestore, it is a
document
database that's  scalable, has
simple -- has a simple
collection of data and allows
you to do powerful queries.
My favorite part, it is how easy
it is
to build offline ready
applications.  This is an app I
made, it is a PWA and I use this
app, this camera app online
just as I can offline and I save
data
and it goes to my weird selfie
feed.  All I have to do to
enable  offline,
it is on the web, I just call an
enable persistence anden o
Android, iOS, it is enable by
default.
But now when we're offline we
have a new responsibility to the
user.   Behavior offline can be
different than behavior online.
We have to build a UI that
guides the
user to make correct decisions.
I have all these pictures, I
don't know if any of these
pictures are synced with the
server.  I don't know if I can
delete them,
what, or if anyone else can see
them.
I can use cloud firestore to
help me out here.  I'll create a
document reference.  I go to the
city's collection, I grab the
document of San Francisco.  I
add a snapshot.
Every single time this document
updates, this snapshot will fire
with the on event listener.
Using this data snapshot I can
go in, get the metadata of the
object and see if it has any
pending rights.
If it has pending rights, then I
know
that this is local-only data,
and if it doesn't, I know it was
synced with the server.
Using this, I can change mine UI
and I can add capacity to my --
to the images so that the user
can see that they are
not synced yet and when it
changes, they
know that the data is now backed
up.
This is great because we're
giving the user proper guidance,
we're giving them an offline
experience and we're letting
them know what's happening while
we're offline.
A lot of the topics I have
covered are about bringing
expectations,
understanding the users'
expectations and you want to
meet the users expectations and
every now and then you go beyond
the expectations and surprise
the user.
Not that long ago, I bought a
house.  The interesting thing
about buying a
house, once you buy it,
everything breaks!
So my hot water heater broke
pretty much the first week I
moved into my house and I had
someone to come out and take a
look at it.  I noticed when
they're inspecting my hot water
heater that they were taking a
picture of it with a custom app
the company built so I asked
them, I said hey, is this useful
for you?  It is surprising, he
looked at me and said no, it is
not.  In the past before I had
this app I wrote down this
manufacturer and the serial
number of the hot water heater
and I was done, now I have to
open the app, take a picture and
I still have to
write down the same information
as before.
I kind of thought this is a
moment where we're not meeting
these user expectations and
we're making things a little
more difficult.  When he left, I
went upstairs, I got to work
I built a little app using ML
kit.  We launch ML kit at the
beginning of -- at the beginning
of this week and ML kit is a
tool to bring machine learning
to mobile devices.
So I created a vision text
detector,
and then I grabbed a UI image
from the view, and then I
converted it to a vision image
and using that, I was able
to detect any text that was in
this photo.
In case you thought that this
wasn't a
real story, this is me.  I'll go
back here.  Can we roll the
video?
This is me in my basement,
scanning
the serial code number of my hot
water heater.  You can see that
in realtime I'm picking up the
text, and then once I see the
code is right, you take the
picture and then I didn't have
to write this information down
and I get the picture
and the serial code number all
at once.
Can we roll forward?
This is what the user wanted.
They don't want two steps.  They
wanted to have the picture and
the serial code number, and this
is something that's going to
happen for the user multiple
times a day.  While it is small,
it has this larger impact and it
just makes their lives a
bit easier in this unexpected
way.
Throughout all of this process,
I
thought to myself UX is not
about fonts, layouts, not about
what color of blue you pick.
User experience, it is about the
moment that a user goes through
it and
in order to really give the user
a 5-star moment, we have to
think about their moment and
think about the developer tools
as a way to create
better moments for the users.
So your feedback for this talk,
it is really important.  I know
you probably heard this in every
single session, but if you have
any feedback, visit the I/O app
and leave that.  It I'll be at
the Firebase tent after this.
If you want to stop by, ask any
questions, take an offline
selfie, I'll be available!
Thank you so much for coming
out!
Opportunities, Challenges &
Strategies to Develop AI for
Everyone
Opportunities, Challenges &
Strategies
to Develop AI for Everyone
Opportunities, Challenges &
Strategies
to Develop AI for Everyone
all right!
Thank you for coming.
Part of Google brain, leader in
the pair
initiative, people  +AI
research.
Here to my side, we have Rejen
Sheth,
director of Cloud management,
and we have Daphne Luong and Jon
Platt,
director of applied science in
Google ai.
Today we'll talk about
opportunities, challenges and
strategies to develop AI for
everyone.
If you could please, I would
love for each of you to just
talk briefly about
what do you do at Google.
>> RAJEN SHETH: I run the
product team for Cloud AI.
What we're doing, within Google
Cloud we're trying to figure out
how to bring
the best of AI to developers and
to enterprises.  How we give
developers a great platform to
build on and how do we take the
best of Google's AI to make it
so
that they're available as
services for developers.
>> DAPHNE LUONG: I work in
Google AI
in the natural language
understanding.
>> JON PLATT: I help run the
applied science within Google
AI.
We're super excited by all the
opportunities in science related
to things like biology or
physics and believe that
computer science, especially
machine learning in AI can
accelerate that.
That's what my work does.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: Thank you.
A thing that's inspiring to me,
about this panel, about a lot of
the themes
going on at I/O this year is AI
for everyone.
I know in pair, one of the main
research themes we have is how
do you design human-centered AI
technology?  How do you start
with a user in mind and then
design machine learning
technology that fits with that.
One of the things I would love
to ask
each of you to talk about a
little bit
is what does AI for everyone
mean to you?
>> RAJEN SHETH: For me it is how
do
you make AI easy and useful for
people that want to use it.  I
think there are two big problems
that we're seeing right now with
AI.
One, that there isn't as much
skill out there or as much
knowledge about how
to build AI models, especially
deep learning as there should
be.  We're trying to both build
tools for that, and to make it
so that more people
can access AI, but then also can
learn about -- learn about AI
and figure out how to use that.
What we're finding, for
example, there are probably in
the tens of thousands of people
out there that know how to use
deep learning, a couple of an
order of a million data
scientists and there are 21
million developers, how do we
make AI accessible by the
developers.
The second part, usefulness, how
do we make AI useful.
How do we go for businesses
beyond where they not only do
cool things but do things that
are useful and actually
are vital to the business.
>> DAPHNE LUONG: To me,
getting
everyone involved and aware so
that algorithms have
representations for all of the
users.  On the data side, it
means that when you have the
data that's representative
of all our users.
>> JON PLATT: For me, it is
getting the benefits of AI to a
large part of society across the
world.  We look for leverage
points.  We're not trying to get
everybody in the world to use AI
but to have the fruits of what
AI can provide.
If we can find the leverage
points, where a local
application of AI can really
help the whole world, that's
what we're looking for.  That's
why I'm super excited about
applying AI and machine learning
to problems and science.   You
know, science can lead to
breakthrough technologies.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: I think one
of the
interesting it things here for
this panel and theme, each of
you is coming from a very
different perspective.  I think
of it you coming from the
product/business side of things,
Daphne, you're helping build the
fundamental blocks like the
data, the fundamental
data creation blocks for doing
this
technology, Jon, you're coming
from a research perspective, how
do we enable scientists and
science at large.
A thing that comes up, whenever
we talk about AI, when we talk
about
machine learning, it is this
notion of representation.  I
want to start at the beginning
of that, I want to talk about
data.  Daphne, I was really
excited when I heard that you
were going to be part of this
panel.
I think about you as the data
czar of Google.  Your work is a
lot about creating
better ways to scale up for
instance how do we gather data?
How do we do it in an insightful
way.  A thing that I would love
for you to
talk about, a little bit, the
representation of datasets at
Google.
What's that look like today?
>> DAPHNE LUONG: Having
meaningful and
systematic correctly calibrated
labeled data at scale is really
crucial for machine learning.
From a representation
perspective, some of the
datasets out there, they're not
well-balanced.   For example, if
you look at Wikipedia
data, right, the he components
is mentioned so much more than
she.  Inside of Google we have a
lot of data.
An example set that I want to
talk
about, it is the audio dataset
that we Open Sourced last year.
The datasets had 2.
1 million video with 8.
5K hours of audio, but then we
had about 500 classes of sound.
That's interesting.  You have
sounds from speech, music,
all the way to engine sounds or
burping
or gurgeling, from that
perspective, it is important to
have audio and sound from the
world.
From having sounds from kids in
India, China, very different
from the U.S.
We think about that when we make
the datasets.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: Yeah. When
I became aware of all the
different Open Sourced datasets
that we have put out, I was
really -- it is
really exciting to see audio,
video tags
to translation, you have all of
those.
Whenever you talk about data and
machine learning you're talking
about challenges.  A thing you
started to touch on a bit,
I want to pull it out more is
the notion
of representation, making sure
that the
dataset has good representation
from different users, different
communities, and that's a hard
thing to do.
I'm curious what are we at
Google doing about that?  How
are you thinking about that?
>> DAPHNE LUONG: You know,
Google
users and  communities, right,
they have been generous donating
data, so forth,
to make the product better and
an example is Google guy, how
many of you have used that in
the audience?  Right.  On the
data front, we're also doing o
something very similar, we have
a crowdsource app which is an
app and on the web, and right
now, since the last two years,
we actually have had 2 million
users donating to the app from
all over the world, actually 232
countries, that's a lot of
different people!  Right?  We
have 200 million donations from
people answering questions all
the way
from hey, can you see this sign
from the street in Indonesia
versus how do you finish this
sentence?  What's the sentiment
of this sentence in Hindi?
There is all of that data.  The
data, it actually helps us make
product better.  It helps people
navigate streets where
there is no sign from landmark,
Marcking the keyboard more
accessible as
well as making heavy detailed
label sets.  That's really
important.  If you don't have
the crowdsource app, please
download it!
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: Great.
Thank you.
A thing about audio that I had
never thought about until I read
this, it is
that there is a huge discrepancy
between even voices of adults
versus children and children --
it is -- so you have to think
about many, many different
dimensions of diversity.
>> DAPHNE LUONG: From the app,
we have
user-initiated groups in 35
countries and I'm really excited
about the whole contributions.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: Awesome.
Now moving on a little bit from
data, one of the  things,
whenever we talk
about AI for everyone, one of
the first questions that comes
to mind is how do
we make AI accessible and better
for our users?
Rajen Sheth, I'll turn to you,
since
you are helping lead these
services on Cloud, right, how do
you think about designing these
ML tools so that they're
easy for users to use.
Then a segue question there too,
if you can talk about the
difficulties
you're starting to see, what are
the patterns where users are
getting stuck?
>> RAJEN SHETH: A great
question.
There are two big parts of
that.  One, how do we make it
easy for people to create models
and the second part, how do we
make sure that the models are
fair or not biased, are really
serving the purpose in the right
way.  It is very easy for people
to just take what they have been
doing manually
and end up encoding into a
model.  On one part of it, what
we're doing, we're providing a
variety of tools.   One of the
more interesting things
we're working on, it is Cloud
auto ML.
Cloud auto ML is a way by which
you can give the dataset and
then we'll use machine learning
to create a machine learning
model for that dataset.  The
first area we're doing this with
is image recognition where you
give us a set of images that are
labeled and we'll give you a
highly accurate model
on top of that to predict for
images.   That's really helped
this expand.  We have 15,000
people that have signed up for
access to that.  We're seeing
amazing use cases, everything
from really large companies to
very small companies who are
doing things around, for
example, helping farmers manage
their field or helping track
litter and making sure that they
track litter back to the
producers.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: How much
technical expertise do I as a
user need to have if
I want to use auto ML?
>> RAJEN SHETH: Great
question, we're
trying to limit it to limited or
no use to use it.
Same as photos, you up load the
pictures, label them, we're
integrating
with a lot of serviceses that
Daphne's team is using to have
us label it and hit train and we
create a model for you.  That
said, getting the right dataset,
it is the key part.  Even if you
don't have to create the model,
you have to create the right
dataset.  Atlanta we're trying
to provide tools to make sure
that people are able to create
the right dataset and figure out
if there are flaws in the
dataset.
On the other side of this,
around bias, we're trying to
figure out tools around that and
also help advise customers with
best practices to make sure that
the dataset that they're putting
in can actually produce the
right results.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: Data
continues to
be a bottle neck.
>> RAJEN SHETH: It is the
foundation of this.  If you have
the wrong data you have
the wrong results.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: Jon, one
of the things, as you have all
been seeing, diversity,
diversity in datasets, also how
do you create the experiences
for users who are not themselves
machine
learning experts to be able to
use the technology.  I'm also
curious to hear from you
about diversity and
representation.  On the side of
machine learning developers and
researchers.  The reason I'm
looking at you, you're working
with scientists.
These are people who are going
to be potentially
meeting custom models, Puching
the envelopes sometimes and they
may not be themselves machine
learning experts.
I'm curious about your thoughts
there.
>> JON PLATT: Right. Science is
getting to be increasingly
data driven, a lot of scientists
like  physicists toes geologists
to biologists, they do their job
by gathering large amounts of
data.  They're getting into data
science.  There is a big
opportunity right now for them
to use machine learning to make
themselves be much more
productive.
The way I look at it, it is kind
of like giving the scientist
thousands of
undergraduate assistance
looking at slides if you can
examine the slides themselves,
you have thousands of assistance
look at it with you.  That's an
example.
I don't think I answered the
question.
I'm excited that we can build
kind of models to help
scientists do specific
things to help accelerate their
research.  We actually
collaborate with scientists to
build these kinds of models.
I don't know if that answers
your question.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: What kind of
scientists are you working with?
>> JON PLATT: Well, applied
science people, there is a bunch
of us working
with biomedical research trying
to understand the core research
ever disease, regenerative
diseases, there are a bunch of
us working on climate and
energy, we're working with TIA
technologies trying to figure
out if we can make fusion
energy, make it commercially
relevant.
We span across biology, physics,
chemistry, we work with people
that
simulate quantum chemistry.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: I guess the
same question I asked Rajen
Sheth, I would ask you, what do
you see as the biggest
difficulties for scientists to
do this kind of work today?  Are
there patterns?  Data,
understanding how to put
together models?  Is it -- what
do you see?
>> JON PLATT: They generally
don't want to build models
themselves.  There is an
increasing crossover between
scientists and computer
scientists.
I think they would prefer to
have a productivity tool, in
other words could they get --
can we help them build a
productivity tool for their own
research and either they can try
to build it themselves if they
know machine learning or we can
help  them.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: Along
those lines,
a thing that I have been very
excited
about, a few months ago folks in
Pair in collaboration with
others at Google
launched cancer  flow.js.
This is really significant in
the sense that what we were
talking about in terms of
Democratizing the technology
and bringing machine learning to
the web, right, tenser flow.
js speaks the native language of
the web, speaks Java script, so
now you have
a whole new set of developers
who can start to take advantage
TensorFlow this technology.
We already are starting to see
some interesting  applications.
For instance, one developer who
decided to create, to train a
model
based on his web camera to make
the mouse move in different
directions just by where he was
looking.  If he looked up, the
mouse would go   up.  If he
looked down, the mouse would go
down.  The reason he did that,
because he was
trying to help a friend who had
suffered
a stroke and became a
paraplegic, that to me,  again,
starts to talk about this
possibility of bringing the
technology into your -- what do
you need, how can
you train these models, for your
specific purposes.
A thing I think as we talk about
Democratizing the technology, as
we talk about bringing it to
everybody, one of
the things I think we at Google
are very
mindful of is that we have to do
that with insight and
responsibility.  Right.
You want to be thinking ahead.
A question I have is since you
are
providing this service, right,
what happens if you have bad
actors trying to
use your service and what
safeguards can you provide?
>> RAJEN SHETH: A great question
that's very top of mind for us.
As we see more people use AI,
we want to make sure that we're
providing those
safeguards whether it is kind of
safeguards or best practices to
make
sure that is the event is used
in the right way.  On one hand,
if you ever the Open Source
technologies, it is hard to
prevent people from doing bad
things if they want to do bad
things.  An advantage we have
with Cloud, we can.
We can put in this terms of
services and acceptable use
policies, things like that to
make sure people are not using
this in the right way.  I think
one thing we're discovering with
AI, it is that we have to
rethink that.  It is not an
infrastructure technology
anymore.  We have to rethink the
uses.
That's something that we're
doing quite a bit.
Another thing that worries me
too.
Beyond just bad actors, people
unintentionally doing things
that might be bad and not even
knowing they are.  It goes back
to things we talked about with
bias and fairness.  In a lot of
cases, people aren't intending
to create something that's
biased but they end up creating
something that's biased because
of the data coming in.  That's
another area we're looking at a
bit.
How do we help people out there,
our
customers, developers, how do we
help them have the tools that we
can do this
well as such as they're not
intentionally creating bad
moments.
>> DAPHNE LUONG: Alongside
tooling, right, I think it is
also important to get people
trained all the way from the
beginning end-to-end, really
mindful of the data diversity,
what you need for data.
We train
an an notator and others to
understand
about best data, best practices
in machine learning.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: Absolutely.
>> JON PLATT: I usually think
about this from the research
perspective
because I'm a researcher, we
write and publish papers.  We
have to think very carefully
about when we write a paper, the
intent is to have a positive
impact on the world.
So before we release the paper,
we say is this going to have a
positive impact on the world or
not?
We can't always predict, there
will be unintended consequences
of releasing technology.
We try to, you know, do the best
we can.
We generally have a bias towards
openness because it is just
generally we have the prior --
it is better to share the
technologies.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: As a
researcher
myself, I love the ethos of just
publishing and Open Sourcing and
I have never been
in a field like this before
where the whole idea is that you
publish as soon
as you have a finding, and then
you submit to a conference.  I
had never seen that before.  I
think it is wonderful.
It means that the field
progresses much faster.
I want to come back to one point
that we were talking about, the
notion of
there may be unintended
consequences even with the best
of intentions, you may not know
that your data is bias or that
there may
be something, one thought that I
love to
put out, this notion that
building tools
so that people can inspect the
data and also opening up the
community of people who inspect
these things.  In pair, for
instance, one of the
things we have been doing,
building tools, visualization
tools that
visualize the entire dataset and
allows you to see that this is
the shape of the the  data, this
is the distribution,
this is what female data points
look
like or male data points.
What this means, because it is
this
kind of user interface where
they experience the
visualization, it means not only
developers can look at this.  It
means that product managers can
look at this.
Executives, different
stakeholders can have a
conversation, sit together, oh,
I don't know, I saw something
strange in the dataset, what do
you think will happen
when we facet it by this
dimension here.
I would love to hear a little
bit of
your thoughts on the importance
of
broadening the conversation
around doing AI for everyone so
that it is not a
conversation that is happening
only amongst developers,
obviously the
developers are super important
but it is a conversation that
needs to happen with
a broader set of stakeholders.
>> RAJEN SHETH: A thought on
that, it is interesting, in the
previous conversation, you
talked about how rapidly this is
going.  A way I usually start
out the presentations to
customers, the first
slide I show a picture of, the
mosaic browser from 1994.  My
point with it, all of us, you
know, we remember back to what
that was, and before that point,
the Internet had been around for
a very long time before that
point.  that was when the
Internet started to go out to
many more people for many more
things.  You start to see
everything from checking sports
scores all the way the
through the eCommerce, all kinds
of things, it opened up
possibilities and questions.
Also questions where there
needed to be more tools.  Tools
to make it easier and tools to
make things safe.
I think we're at 1994,ish we're
at that point for AI right now.
It is used for years and years
and years, and now it is used in
many, many more ways.
I think we need to think about
new problems that are starting
to come up every single day, and
new technologies
are coming out every single day.
We're going to think about that,
not just as a developer
community and then
in coordination with how it is
used and
the people it is affecting.
>> JON PLATT: We were just
talking about the first spam
detector before we came up in
1997.
That -- I remember the first
small
email that was sent in the 80s
so it is
as new problems come up, you
need new
tools to kind of help fight the
problem.
>> RAJEN SHETH: For a long time
you didn't need a spam detector
and then all of a sudden you
did, you had to have tools to be
able to work with it.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: Another
thing, another aspect of this,
of broadening the conversation,
especially when talking about
products also, it is this notion
of having in the same room your
technical team, your design
team, for
instance, and the PMs, so forth.
A thing that we're doing at
Google, it
is finding ways of involving the
designers, the UXers from the
beginning
and educating them around
machine learning as a design
material.
How do you think about that as
little as the material you'll
design with.
If you think about it, it is a
very challenging material.
It is something that each person
in a product may have a slightly
different user experience.  My
experience may be very different
from yours.  Certain things may
be automated in different ways
for different people at
different times.
It makes the UX, the user
interaction, much more
challenging.
That space becomes a lot bigger.
So again, when we're talking
about AI
for everyone, it really means
this conversation that needs to
happen
between multiple parties.
A thing I have to come back to
before
we run out of time, John, it is
this notion of science.  One of
the things that I think there's
a lot of excitement around, it
is that machine learning could
be a new paradigm for
scientists.
That finally we could solve
certain
very complex scientific problems
using these new tools.
I'm curious about your thoughts
as why
is it that AI makes such a
difference in
these very complex spaces.
>> JON PLATT: That's an
excellent question.
Right now the current State of
AI and
machine learning, it is still
very
perceptible, we're good at
looking at images, listening to
sounds.  You can imagine as I
said before, I would like to
talk about these thousands of
undergraduates, they would be
listening, looking at the data
and that's a great productivity
term for science.  In the long
run, people are starting to
research into this, but in the
long
run, what we really want is
something where the algorithm,
the machine learning, it tries
to find out what caused what.
It is  very, very early in
research but that's almost the
essence of a scientific model
explains, you know,
this caused that and you can
extrapolate if you know what the
model is.
That's the long term trend for
AI but we're not there yet.
We don't -- our models don't
really
understand causation yet yet.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: We had a
visiting scientist in our group
in cambridge.
He's an earthquake scientist,
he's a professor at Harvard and
he came and spent half a year
with us.
A thing I thought of that was
incredibly inspiring about what
he was
doing, obviously as an
earthquake scientist you want to
predict earthquakes, it is
incredibly hard.
We can't don't it well, yet.
The thing that he was able to
do, I don't know anything about
earthquake science, he explained
to me this is the
kind of science that lives in
HPC high performance computing.
Huge, huge computers that will
spend
entire weeks doing very, very
gnarly  compilations, trying to
simulate where an aftershock
happens after an earthquake
quake, something that people in
California should care a lot
about, I'm sure you do.
Imagine something that takes a
week
running on huge computers, okay,
he was
able to get these kinds of
simulation
results that were just as good
using a simple neural net, it
was so simple, the neural net
was so simple that it was the
kind of neural net where you
could count the neurons was how
simple it was.
One, he was stunned, and
incredibly happy because it
meant that he wouldn't have to
wait a whole week and using a
ton of computer power to do the
same kind of simulations he was
doing.
Then, so that in itself was a
win, then the deeper question,
and one of the
things that gives me a lot of
excitement
is what exactly was this neural
net figuring out about the
physics of the
earth that we haven't figured
out yet.
Again, if we can interpret what
this
is doing, what this neural net
is doing, if we learn from it,
could we become better
scientists ourselves?  You're
starting to see this in science,
starting to see this in
medicine, so for instance, the
brain
work with diabetic
retinopathy where the image is
looking
at the back of the eyes, the
fundus and
they're not only able to
understand
whether or not you have the
diabetic
retinopathy, but they're also
able to do
things like understand the
gender of the
patient and the cardiovascular
risk, the
cardiovascular disease risk,
things that doctors themselves
couldn't necessarily see in
these images.
Part of the race now is to
understand
what are the systems learning
that we couldn't learn.
Could we be better doctors,
scientists, right, by using this
kind of -- can we learn back?
Can we listen back from these
machines.
We have a few more minutes to
go.  I have a few more
questions.
What are you seeing of the
ability of
AI to really help businesses?
I'm curious on what have been
the most successful cases, but
also some of the most
surprising, you're like I didn't
know we could do AI for this?
>> RAJEN SHETH: There are a
bunch of things we have seen.
There are definitely certain
industries further  ahead, tech
industry, there is a lot being
used, financial services, there
is a lot being used.  There are
many emerging use cases which I
think are pretty amazing.  Some
of the examples we have seen,
like on the manufacturing line,
can you use vision to figure out
if a part is okay or not?  If a
tire coming down the factory
line is going to be a good tire
or it might actually bare risk
to the person, those
kinds of things, things that
we're seeing.
Retail, another case, how do you
make it so that you make the use
of the ex persons together t an
example, we use
auto ML with Disney, my son is a
massive lightning Mcqueen fan
from  Cars.  I'm sure many of
you have kids or
family members that are big
Disney fans.
He has an appetite for Disney
stuff and the stuff with
lightning Mcqueen, with the
technology we have developed,
you can search on Disney's -- on
shop Disney for everything with
lightning
Mcqueen on it, whether or not it
says it in the description or
not, they can do it by visual
inspection.
Those are things that are
interesting use cases.  We're
starting to see that.
A thing that I think is
important though, we need to get
businesses to a point where
they're not thinking about hey,
I'm using AI to do this, but
where the users are  feeling
magic and it doesn't matter if
it is AI behind the
covers or not and that's why the
things we have done with Google
photos, it is incredible, it is
not about AI but the user
experience.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: Awesome.
We talk about the challenges,
some of the strategies.
I want to end on the
opportunities.  We talked about
some opportunities also.  I want
to end on that note, on the
opportunities.
In the last year we have seen AI
being
applied to various domains in
really interesting ways.  You
have medicine, science, you have
farming, right, we talked about
some of those examples.
I would love to hear from each
one of you what opportunities
are you excited
about for the next however many
years.
You want to start?
>> JON PLATT: Okay.
You mentioned biomedical
research, I can't talk about
that!  Let me talk about another
project I find really exciting
which I mentioned before, which
is we're actually working
to see if we can get a fusion
energy to be a real commercial
source of energy in
order to displaces to fossil
fuels and right now we're
flooding the atmosphere with
carbon
deoxide and we're using machine
learning and we're trying to
optimize
the experiments, helping them
design the experiments and using
methods to actually help them
debug the plasma inside of the
machine so the goal, it is
going to be trying to make this
plasma about as hot as the
center of the sun
and if we can do that, we can
measure its heat loss rate and
see if we can actually get to
commercially relevant fusion
which would revolutionize the
world.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: When can we
expect that?
>> JON PLATT: Well, I don't want
to promise anything.
We'll have good scientific
results I think in 2019.  We
won't have what they call break
even fusion then, but we'll have
very solid results predicting
the heat loss rate.
We'll know a lot more in about a
year.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: Awesome.
>> DAPHNE LUONG: I'm excited
about two things.
The first, really we'll continue
to
work with the crowdsource
contributors
that built globally diverse
dataset that not a single
company could build by itself
but actually leveraging everyone
who is passionate about
representing their part of the
world to create dataset to Open
Source to use by everyone and
then similarly for machine
learning, since I do a lot of
volunteering outside of work, we
have social entrepreneurs around
the world, I
really want to see that ML
available for
non-profits, you know, to do
sort of air
quality models, maybe using
translate to make books
available for thousands of
different languages and for
mother tongues, it I'm excited
about that, looking forward to
that.
>> RAJEN SHETH: Two things I'm
passionate about, one healthcare
and the other is education.
Healthcare, just this idea like
you
talked about, being able to use
AI to do easterly disease
detection, you have an
incredible somebody impact on
one human
being and on many human beginses
and on families around them,
things like that.
That's a I amazing.
Education, I spend a lot of my
time working on the education
products.
The idea of  imagining an
environment where every student
can learn in the way that they
want to learn at their own pace
in their own style and having AI
help power that can be
transformative.  You can pull
the potential and actually make
-- harness the potential of
every single individual that was
never possible before.
>> FERNANDA VIEGAS: I'm going
to segue
from that and say again, one of
the
things that's been really
inspiring to see with things
like tenser flow.
js, it is that we have now
professors at a number of
universities who were
building educational materials
around this and I feel that's
really important and I'm really
excited about this.
It not only lowers the barrier
for
entry in this technology, but it
also I
think starts to hit a much more
diverse set of developers who
are interested in
using this technology for
different
things that we haven't even
dreamt of yet.
I'm very excited about that.
The other thing that I think is
really
good to see is how the
conversation
around machine learning has been
-- has started to touch on
things like ethics
and fairness.  I think that's
really important.   I'm really
happy it that here at
Google we think very deeply
about these questions, and both
from a research perspective,
what are research things we can
do to help address some of these
problems, but also, you know,
policy, product wise, design
wise, what are -- it is a
broader conversation.
With that, I'm going to thank
our panel.  Thank you so much.
It has been inspiring to hear
your insights and have you share
your experience as you have said
from many different parts of
Google on this topic today with
us.
Thank you.  Thank you.
How to Build a User Base for
your Actions.
Stage 8.
2:30 p.m.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello, everyone! Thank you
all for coming.
It is so exciting to see you
here.
My name is Tanya Gupta, and I am
a
Product Manager on the Google
Assistant, focusing on natural
language understanding and
discovery of  third-party
actions.
>> DINA ELHADDAD: And this is
Dina Elhaddad.
I'm also a Product Manager on
the Assistant team and I lead
the discovery and engagement.
>> TANYA GUPTA: We're here
today to talk to you about how
to make your action more
discoverable, and build a
strong and consistent user base
.
>> DINA ELHADDAD: These
shouldn't be a surprise to you
at this point.  The Assistant is
a large and ever growing
ecosystem.
We have over 1 million actions
across
more than 500 million devices in
more than 25locales.  Now the
question is:  How can you stand
out?
How can you get a share of that
user base?
>> TANYA GUPTA: Many of you may
recognize this and see the
similarity to
a marketing funnel, and a lot of
building a user base is creating
a brand that users recognize
immediately.  We've broken this
funnel into three stages:  The
first and biggest stage is all
about creating awareness for
your action, so that users know
that it
exists, and what they can use it
for.
Once they know about your
action, the second stage is all
about creating an engaging
experience so that users are
immediately hacked.
And the last stage is about
retaining
users so they come back day
after day, week after week, year
after year.  For all three of
these stages we'll talk about
different techniques and
different tools you can use to
improve your action.
Let's jump right in and talk
about some of the ways you can
build awareness around your
action and make it more
discoverable to users.
>> DINA ELHADDAD: There are
various
discovery opportunities in
Google Assistant, starting from
the Assistant directly to in
conversation suggestions to in
app discovery to built-in
intents.
You can even ask Google
Assistant what can you do?  And
it whether even respond back
with relevant actions to
treatment now let's jump and
focus on the Assistant directly,
also known as  Explore.
Explore is a one stop shop for
all Assistant actions.
It's available on web at
Assistant.google.
com/explore and in the Assistant
app on both Android and iOS.
The directory is interesting,
because
we see that more than 30% of our
third-party actions being
discovered and used directly
from there.
So now let's walk through the
different user flowing that are
supported in Explore, and how
you can optimize each of them.
One of the primary use cases for
Explore is browsing.
When we designed the landing
page for Explore, we made sure
that the most relevant and
personal recommendations are
shown at the top of the page
with less relevant held shuns
shown as you scroll down.
At the high level, there are
three key
areas to highlight on the
landing page.  First, we have
contextual suggestions.  These
are relevant recommendations
based on the users context such
as time and location.
For example, I can see here that
for my
morning, I can play my favorite
playlist or listen to my daily
brief.
Next comes dynamic categories.
To date, we have 4 of these:
What's new, which highlights new
high-quality actions.
What's popular, which highlights
overall popular actions.  What's
trending, which highlights newly
popular actions.  And you might
like, which recommends action
that the user may like based on
their history with Assistant.
We have also just launched
editorial pics.  This is a new
feature highlighting high
quality and seasonal actions
through visual campaigns.
An interesting fact about the
landing page is that we see that
actions that get promoted on
that page specifically in
dynamic categories are 10 times
more likely to be used on that
day.
If you ask me, how can I ensure
that my action gets featured in
the landing page?  I would say
that the main ingredient here is
quality, and quality can mean a
variety of things.
It means solid ratings, positive
reviews, steady health signals,
among other things.
The second use case that Explore
supports is categorical browsing
and search.  Here, we're trying
to expose the user to the
variety of actions available
within a category of interest,
whiles
allowing the user to easily find
their favorite actions through a
quick search.  Let's say, for
example, I'm interested in food
and drink.  By going to that
category, I can see
all the relevant actions grouped
by helpful  subcategories.
For example, I can see here that
I can
order food from Dunkin' Donuts
and domino's pizza, whereas I
can find recipes from Food
Network.
As for search and autocomplete,
the idea is to expose the user
to the variety of capabilities
supported by an
action of interest, whiles also
providing predictive suggestions
to the user based on the key
term.  If you want to make sure
your action
is showing in the right category
and is being searched for the
right key terms
you want to ensure your display
same, your description and
sample invocations are
reflective of your action and
actually includes useful
keywords.  Finally and most
importantly, let's
move to the action page.  The
Action Page is a welcome action.
It should reflect your brand and
invite the user to try your
action out.
At a glance the Action Page
consists of two main sections.
The top section provides the
user with a quick summary of
what your action does, through
your imagery description and
sample invocation the user
should get an idea about your
action before trying it out.
The second section covers more
details.
The user can see your ratings
and our newly launched reviews.
This allows the user to assess
the quality of your action
before giving it a try.
Now that we've walked through
the main user flows, how can you
optimize your page and really
shine in the directory?  Let's
go through an example.
I'm a French bulldog over and I
wanted to post an action about
French bulldogs.  On the left, I
chose a short and
concise name, French bulldog
trivia.
It explains exactly what my
action does and it fits nicely
on the screen.
The right I picked a long
display name
that got caught up and I used
redundant keywords such as "the
best."
On the left for my imagery I
created graphics based on my
dogs.  They're  iconic and they
look great on a large screen.
On the right, I used the
distorted picture of my dogs.
Though undeniably cute, it
doesn't look great on a large
screen, and it doesn't reflect
well on my brand.
For my description, on the left,
I wrote a short and glancable
description, but I made sure
that all the important
keywords to me are there,
keywords such
as:  Frenchies, French bulldog
lovers, dog lovers, dogs, and
facts.
This is great, as it will
potentially
allow my action to be searched
for these key terms.  On the
right I have a long
description, and I didn't use
any useful keywords.  Finally
for my sample invocations, on
the left, I maximized the number
of sample invocations on the
screen.  I also made sure that
they were
descriptive, instead of just
limiting  myself to talk to
French bulldog trivia, I used
more descriptive sample
invocations such as ask French
bulldog about grooming.  If you
want your Action Page to really
shine in the directory, you want
to do these four things --
You want to have a short and
unique display name.
You want to have a descriptive
yet glancable description.
You want to have 5 sample
invocations that are
descriptive, and you want to use
high-quality graphics.
As mentioned, you're encouraged
to use relevant keywords to your
action, but don't overdo it and
definitely don't include
keywords that are not relevant
to your action.  Otherwise, you
may be penalized.
Now, let's switch gears a bit
and talk about in conversation
discovery through built-in
intents.
>> TANYA GUPTA: Another
important aspect to building
awareness is to Surface your
action when it's most relevant
to the user.  One such
opportunity is when the user is
interacting directly with the
Assistant.
But natural language
understanding is hard.  In
addition to the multitudes of
languages, there's dialects,
there's slang, and there's
cultural variations that
increase the number of ways that
a user can express the same
thing.
So let's take an example of some
of the ways that a user can
express that they're stressed
out and they want to calm down.
These examples here are just
some of the ways users would say
it in American English.  It
doesn't include other variations
of English, such as British
English or Indian English.  Then
when you start thinking about
other  languages, you could
imagine just how long this list
would be.
Well, I work with a team of
expert
linguists to define intents that
capture all of these natural
language variations into one
definition.
As Brad mentioned in the
developers
keynote, these built in intents
are a common taxonomy to
describe actions across Google
Surfaces^.
As a developer, you can
integrate your
action with a relevant built-in
intents
and this allows Google to handle
the natural language
understanding and the semantic
parsing for you.  Google will
extract the relevant parts of
the queries and pass it to your
action in a structured format.
So let's take a few of these
queries,
and see what they look like as a
built-in intent.
On the right here, you can see
that
we've defined the intent and
called it start calming
activities.  We've also
identified three arguments.
The first is activity the user
wants to partake  in.  Second is
how long they want to
partake in that activity and
third is a reason why they're
stressed out.
On the left you can see how
we've mapped
the queries to the built-in
intent so in that second
example, we've extracted
breathing exercises and mapped
it to the
calming activity, and we've
extracted
the my interview, and that
became the stressor.
Built-in intents make it so that
developers don't need to worry
about the natural language
variations.  You just need to
make sure that you can fulfill
all of the arguments
specified by the built-in
intent.
Another benefit to built-in
intents is that it gives Google
information about the type of
queries that your action can
handle, and how good it is in
responding to those queries.
Google can then use that info to
apply AI, and Surface your
action when it's most relevant
to the user.
On the screen here, you see some
explorations on how built-in
intents can
be used to makings more
discoverable.  So, for example,
on the left there,
the user has asked to check
their Leo horoscope and is
presented with four high quality
actions that Google is confident
can fulfill that request.
Built-in intents are not just
limited to the Assistant.  In
previous sessions, you may have
heard about app actions and how
it is also built on built-in
intents.  What that means is
that when you integrate your
action with a built-in
intent, not only are you
creating opportunities discovery
across the Assistant but across
a variety of Surfaces such as
Google Play and Google search
search.  So now I know all of
you are itching to find out how
to integrate with a built-in
intent, so let's do a quick
demo.
Can we switch to the laptop,
please?
So here you can see that we've
signed
into dialogue flow, and I've
already
selected my action here called
breathing Buddha.
I have a series of intents I've
defined and to integrate with a
built-in intent I can create a
new intent.  Let's call this
intent "demo."
Inside of the events section, I
can see all of the built-in
intents that are available for
me to integrate with.
Given that my action is about
meditating and breathing
exercises, I think start calming
activity probably makes the most
sense.
So here, I can see a few example
queries that would map to this
built-in
intent, as well as all of the
arguments.
Now, the proper way to fulfill
this intent would be to create a
Webhook where I could parse the
argument values and respond to
the user accordingly, but for
the sake of time, I'm just going
to create a simple response
here.
I can save my intent, and try it
out in the simulator.
Now, as usual, I could choose to
speak directly to my action, but
let's try one of the queries
that I know maps to this
built-in  intent.
All right, as you can see here,
I'm presented with a list of
four actions
that I can use to meditate for
one hour.  Let's switch over to
the phone, and try it on on the
real Assistant.
I want to meditate for one hour.
>> Assistant: All right, which
one would you like to try?
>> TANYA GUPTA: Again you can
see the same actions, with my
action being the first one
there.
Let's switch back to the slides,
please.
We are excited to announce
built-in
intents as part of Google I/O,
these are just some of the
intents that we're
working on this year, and the
ones with the stars next to them
are already available as a
developer's preview.
So I encourage all of you to
sign into dialogue flow, try
them out, familiarize yourselves
with them, and see how they can
fit into your action.
So with that, we've talked about
two different ways that you can
build  awareness for your
action.  First, by optimizing
the Assistant Directory page.
And, second, by integrating with
built-in intents.
Now that your action is
discoverable, let's jump to the
next stage, which focuses on
creating an engaging
experience so that users are
immediately hooked.
>> DINA ELHADDAD: In the
Assistant team, we assess our
product through the
lens of critical user journeys.
We built Google Assistant to
help our users throughout their
day and based on research and
from analyzing usage behavior we
have seen we truly offer values
in three key moments:  In the
morning, during the commute, and
in the evening.
In the morning, we help our
users from the minute they get
out of bed till they head out of
the door.  From setting alarms
to checking the weather to
listening to the news, the
Assistant is always there.
Next comes the commute journey.
Imagine you are driving to work
and you have a million things on
your mind.  The Assistant can
make that time productive.  It
could help you with navigation,
listening to your favorite
podcast or even rescheduling
your next meeting.  Finally
comes the evening journey, the
time to destress.  The Assistant
is still there for you.  It
could help you with things like
control your smart home devices,
play
relaxing music or help you cook
a meal.
Now, as a developer, whether you
focus
on morning productivity, media
on the go, or smart home, by
focusing on one of those
critical user journeys you'd be
optimizing for moments where we
truly believe we can offer
assistance to our users.
This will automatically lead to
higher engagement and will
potentially lead to more organic
discovery opportunities.
Another key source for
engagement is our
newly launched Action Links.
Action  Links are hyperlinks
that point directly to your
action.  They make your action
discoverable from any platform
or Surface.
They allow users to engage
directly with your action
irrespective of how they found
this link, whether on a website,
in a social media campaign, or
even on a billboard.  I am
personally considering having a
billboard for my action.  Isn't
it awesome?
On the Assistant side, we're
going to promote these links
everywhere.  You're going to
start seeing these links on your
Action Page in the directory.
This will allow users to try
your action easily, and engage
with you directly.
If they had a good experience,
they're also going to be able to
share it with their friends.
Supporting Action Links is very
easy.
All you need to do is go to the
actions console.  Over there,
you can publish a URL for your
action, and choose a title for
your link.  Once you do that,
you will instantly get a link
that you can start sharing.
Once you have a published link,
you're encouraged to promote it
everywhere.
You might have seen this in the
developers' keynote, but head
space has built some great
experiences on Google Assistant,
helping users  meditate.  They
also happen to have a really
engaged social following.  Now
every time they have a new
update since they have an action
link, they can direct their
users directly to that  update.
They can do so through a blog
post like anyway have done so on
Tuesday, or through a quick
Tweet.
So just to recap, so far, we
have talked about awareness
through the Assistant Directory
and built-in  intents,
engagement through critical user
journeys and Action Links.  Now
let's move to the last piece of
the funnel:  Retention.
>> TANYA GUPTA: Retention is
all about
creating a loyal base of users
that derive value your action.
Not only do these users bring
consistent traffic, but they
also eventually become your
evangelists, and they feed the
funnel by creating awareness for
your action.
So how do you go about building
these loyal users?
The best way is a lot of what
Dina
talked about, by creating a
high-quality
action with dynamic and unique
content that users find
meaningful.
Once you're confident that your
action does this, there are a
few tools that you can leverage
to re-engage and
maintain a relationship with a
user.
The first feature allows you to
send an update on a daily basis
to the user at a time specified
by them.  Let me give you a
personal example of how I like
to use this feature.  Every day
at 2:00 p.m.
, I like to grab a coffee and
just
escape from work for a few
minutes and  destress.
I'm also an avid story-reader
and reading stories really
relaxes me, so I set up this
feature so that every day, as
I'm getting my coffee, I receive
an update with a story to read.
Another feature that helps with
re-engaging users is the push
notifications feature.  As the
name denotes, this feature
allows you to push a
notification to the user
whenever your action deems it
appropriate.
Let's say, for example, your
action
tracks cryptocurrency prices,
and there's a fluctuation in the
price.  Your action can
automatically push an  update to
the user so that the user can
take the appropriate response.
Both of these features can be
enabled for your action inside
of the actions on Google
Console.  Once you've enabled
it, you can start prompting
users to see if they'd like to
receive these updates or these
notifications from your action.
The last tool that I want to
talk about builds on the key
user journeys that Dina talked
about as part of the engagement
section.  We really believe that
these are some
of the best times that the
Assistant can provide the most
benefit to the user.
For this reason, we built the
routines assistance feature
which allows the user
to customize the information
that they
receive when they trigger a
routine.  So for example, when I
say  hey, Google, good morning,
I've customized my
phone to take itself off of
silent, to
tell me about may commute, the
weather, as well as may first
meeting, and then kick it into
my favorite music.
As a developer, you can also
enable your action to be
incorporated as part of a
routine.
Following the same model as the
daily updates, once you enable
this for your action, you can
start prompting users to see if
they'd like to incorporate it as
part of one of their routines.
After the user does so, the next
time
they trigger a routine, your
action will automatically get
called.
Another important aspect to
retaining users is to make sure
that users can have a smooth and
free-flowing conversation with
your action.
Have you ever had that situation
where you walked up to someone
and you asked them a question,
and they just didn't get it?  So
you rephrased it a little bit,
hoping that they'd be able to
understand you this time, and
they shrugged their shoulders?
So you try one last time, a
third time, hoping that they'd
be able to answer and tell you
what you're looking for?  And
they still could not help you.
How frustrating was that
experience?
In the same way, you want to
make sure that your action
understands your user, and is
able to give it the information
that it's looking for.
We have a few tools that you can
use to ensure that.  The first
is a session flow feature inside
of dialogue flow, which allows
you to analyze the conversation
flow users having with your
action.
Let's take the session flow of
the
mobile legends action as an
example.  This action was built
a little over a
month  ago, and quickly Rose to
become a top-10 action globally,
so it makes for a great case
study.  The action for those of
you who aren't
familiar with it is based on the
mobile legends game and it tells
users about the different
characters from the game.
So you can see from the session
flow
here that about 97% of users
that start a conversation do so
in the default welcome intent,
where they're presented
a list of characters to choose
from.
Let's dig a little bit deeper
and see where the conversation
goes from here.
As you can see, session flow
allows you to break down the
conversation on a  per-intent
basis.
I was able to click on the
default welcome intent, and see
what the next set of intents
that triggered from there.
In this case, about 57% of users
clicked
on one of the characters to
learn about it.  I'm going to
dig one level deeper, and see
what happened from there.
41% of users that selected a
character
read about the character, and
then 32% dropped off from there,
as we can see from that red line
coming out of the intent.
Session flow is a powerful tool
for you to identify what the
most popular intents in your
action are.  This is great if
you're looking to expand your
action, and want to see how
users are already leveraging it.
The second thing that I would
recommend using session flow for
would be to use
it to identify where the large
drop-offs are.  Maybe there's
certain intents where it's just
not understanding the user, or
it's not providing the user the
information they're seeking.
Identifying these  drop-offs is
a great way to ensure that
you're not losing users when
they interact with your action.
And the last thing I'd encourage
you to use this feature for
would be to identify the intents
that just aren't
getting any love, and that might
mean
restructuring your action so
that users
can find those intents much more
easily.
Another tool I want to quickly
touch
upon is the history feature
inside of  Dialogueflow.  This
feature allows you to see the
most popular queries that users
are issuing to your action.
It's a great way of ensuring
that your action responds in the
appropriate way, and is giving
the user what they're looking
for.
You can also see a few of these
queries
have an exclamation mark next to
it.  That's never a good thing.
These exclamation marks mean
that either your action could
not be reached or that it gave
the default fall-back
intent, or worst of all, it just
quit.
In all after these cases, that
is a poor user experience, and
the user is less likely to
engage again with your action.
Now, we've talked about two
different aspects to retaining
users.
The first is talking about
creating a smooth conversation,
and the second was all about --
what was the second one?
>> DINA ELHADDAD: Metrics?
>> TANYA GUPTA: Oh, yeah, so
this is all about creating the
metrics, right?  It's always
important to keep a lookout on
the metrics to ensure that
your users having a good
experience, and their action is
performing consistently.  So
let's talk about a few metrics
that are particularly important.
The first is a star rating that
users are giving your action.
These star ratings are a good
signal as to whether users
enjoyed your action and are
likely to come back.
Ideally, the star ratings should
be always either be 5-star or
4-star, and if you're seeing a
lot of one-star and 2-stars,
that means something is going
wrong and it needs to be fixed.
Other ratings to keep a lookout
on are
things like:  Active users,
average conversation length,
messages and abort rate.  All of
these should be what you expect
them to be.  You want your abort
rate to be low.  You want your
active users to be high.
You want your average
conversation length to be what
it is.  If you see any
deviations, that means  again
something has gone wrong with
your action.
So we've talked about a lot of
different things in this
session.  Let's quickly recap
what they were.
We broke the funnel into three
parts:  The first was we talked
about awareness, where we talk
about two different tools.
First, optimizing for the
Assistant Directory page.  And,
second, integrating with
built-in intents.
The second was about creating an
engaging experience, and this
could be
done by tailoring for the key
user journeys where the
Assistant can provide the most
benefit.
And the last part of the funnel
was
about retaining users so that
they come back repeatedly.  And
here we talked about creating a
compelling  conversation, and
using
metrics to identify pitfalls.
>> DINA ELHADDAD: This
concludes our talk for today but
we would love to hear you
feedback.
You can do so at  Google.com/I/O
or in the app.  We'll be having
Office hours at 3:30 in the
Office hours tent section.  If
you can swing by and ask
questions and get your action
reviewed.  We'd also love to see
you in our sandbox.  Thank you
so much, guys.  Hope you enjoy
the rest of I/O.
[ Applause ]
[ End of session ]
>> If you've registered for the
next section in this room, we
ask that you please clear the
room and return via the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
.
Google Play Instant:  How Game
Developers are Finding Success.
Stage 8.
3:30 p.m.
.
>> Hello! And welcome to what
is almost certainly the last
session you'll be attending here
this week.
I'm Ben Frenkel, Product Manager
on the Google Play Instant team
and I focus on games.
Today we have Jam City, King and
Zynga with us to talk about
Google Play Instant.  But before
we get started I'm going to
provide you some context for the
panel discussion.
So last year at I/O we launched
instant apps and since then
we've been pretty busy.
We've enabled instant apps on
over one billion devices and
we've made major improvements to
our tooling and Android
Studio, and most recently, at
the game developer conference in
March, we announced that instant
apps was finally coming to
games.  And this week, we were
excited to
announce that Google Play
Instant is now
available to all game
developers.  Now, let's take a
look at Google Play Instant in
action.
[ Music ]
.
>> Goodbye!
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: So King's
Candy Crush team just launched
that app this past Tuesday day
and you can check it out on the
Play Store today.  So just think
about that for a second.  That's
Candy Crush, one of the most,
if not the most, successful
mobile games
ever coming to Google Play
Instant, and what gets partners
like King excited is
the vision that bringing Instant
to games can transform game
discovery, and
we know that this is possible
because we have seen this movie
before.
Whenever media becomes instant,
consumption goes up.  Speed is a
huge competitive advantage.
We've seen this with streaming
music
and movies, and before that,
Google
proved the  transformative
impact of speed with  Instant
Search.
And we want to do the same thing
for
games, because we believe that
Instant
will do the same thing for you,
the game developer.
Imagine users trying more games,
Exploring more genres, and
ultimately finding more games
they love to play.  That would
have a  transformative impact on
your business, and over the
course of our early access
program, the data has proven
this theory out.
Today, the most visible entry
point to an instant app is the
Try Now button, as you can see
here.  And with just the Try Now
button, partners are already
seeing an up to 20% increase in
user acquisitions.
Again, that impact is from Try
Now
alone, which just scratches the
Surface
of the overall Google Play
Instant opportunity.
People will also be able to
discover
your games through ads, through
the play games app, through
social invites and banners and
collections on the Play Store.
And today, we're announcing that
Instant
Apps is coming soon to
pre-registration.  Soon, players
that pre-register can also get a
sneak preview of your game.
And when you promote
reregistration through social
media, email or your website,
users can instantly play that
game from any Android device.
It's an awesome way to introduce
your game to the world.
And as you look at what our
partners
have done with the discovery
services that I just described
and you hear about what they're
excited about doing in the
future, you'll start to see how
important a role Google Play
Instant can play throughout the
lifecycle of a game.
From the pre-launch Phase, when
your goal is to make your launch
as big as
possible, to build the hype
machine around your game, and
once you've had that big launch
and you've acquired a bunch of
users, you want your game to go
viral.  You want your players to
invite their friends to the
party, so to speak.  And after
your game has been around for a
while, your goals end up
changing.
Your focus then turns to
retaining your
existing players, and bringing
back those that may have
churned.
At each stage, the right instant
experience can play an integral
role in your game's success.
And there are three times of
instant experiences among the
many, many that we saw among our
partners.  It was very difficult
to choose just these three.  But
I wanted to highlight these
three today for you.  The first
is the minigame.  A minigame is
often a gaming
experience that is complimentary
to the
full game, and is a great fit
for  pre-registration.
Dancevil's minigame let's you
choreographic a routine by
manipulating the individual
limbs on this awesome looking
character and once you're done
you can share an animated  GIF
with all of your friends.  It
offers endless combinations of
moves and plenty of
entertainment to occupy players
all the way through to
the event you'll launch of the
game.
The second is what I'm calling
the core gameplay preview.
And the goal of this archetype
is to provide a glimpse of what
players will experience after
the tutorial and introductory
levels.
This is a great game and a great
type
for different experiences that
have a deep upgrade system, for
example, such as zombie Gunship
Revenant, like you can see here,
and this example, the
installed app at the top
typically starts you off with a
single weapon.  It's not unusual
to let people slowly acclimate
to new game mechanics and so
forth.  So you start off with a
single machine
gun, and the zombie horde that's
arriving is arriving at a
relatively modest pace.
Contrast this with the instant
experience, which you can see
down here on the left.
In this one, you don't just get
one machine gun, but you get two
machine guns.
You get a high-powered sniper
rifle and hellfire missiles.
The whole experience is intended
to
get your adrenaline pumping, and
is a
great fit for Try Now, for ads
and other user acquisition
channels.
And if you're focused on
bringing back churned users, the
game highlights pattern might be
the right fit for you.
The Candy Crush experience is a
great example of this.
To build their Instant app, the
Candy Crush team selected five
levels from the more than 3,000
available in the full
game, starting with Level 16,
going all
the way up to  Level 90 and each
was selected to highlight a
unique combination of game
mechanics.  I really like
playing level 590 which you can
see here.  There's a convey or
belt which Mavs candies around
and there's this fascinating
portal in the mid Olof it which
you can't see it now, and
through which candies magically
disappear.  The goal of this
type of experience is to provide
a glimpse of what you've been
missing out on since the last
time you played.  And it's very
effective.
So now that you have a sense of
the role Google Play Instant can
play throughout the lifecycle of
a game, let's turn our attention
to how you build these types of
experiences.  And just like we
want to make it as easy as
possible for users to start
playing your games, we also want
to make
it easier for you, the game
developer, to build these
experiences.
And we've mad
made substantial  investment.
First we have the framework to
meet the unique needs of game
developers.  We made three
changes.
We raised the size limit to 10
megabytes.
Enabled the download of assets
and executable Code and we
integrated with game engines and
added support for native Code
and OpenGL and that last point
is vitally important because it
means you can use the same Code
base as
your full game to build your
instant app and by integrating
with game engines like Unity,
we've made it possible to build
with the tools you're already
familiar with.
To make this possible for Unity
developers, possibly many of you
in the audience here today, we
have to work closely with the
world's most widely
used game engine, Unity.
Through this close collaboration
millions of Unity developers
will be able to optimize their
current and future games for
Google Play Instant.
And to that end, we've built the
Google Play Instant Unity
plugin.  The plugin simplifies
building and
deploying an instant app all
from within
the Unity IDE and it will become
available in the coming weeks.
If you're a Unity developer and
want
to start building an instance
experience today we represented
you join our Unity Beta Program.
You can sign up at the link in
the lower left-hand corner and
I'll review this at the end so
you don't have to immediately
break out your photos and take a
picture.  If you sign up today,
you'll get the latest news and
access to beta features.
We're also excited to announce
that
Cocos has added instant support
to their IDE Cocos Creator and
they've gone beyond supporting
Google Play Instant as a build
target by adding tools that
simplify the process of building
an instant app.
Cocos has added two steps to
their standard build process
just for this purpose:  Record
and refactor steps.  On the
recording step, you play your
game in the Cocos simulator
which tracks
which assets are used and when.
Then in the refactor step you
use a visual  non-linear editing
style tool to
define the boundaries of your
instant experience, and assets
are broken down by category.  As
you can see here, to support
further optimizations.
Cocos has made an alpha build
available for the adventure us
to try and you can check it out
today.
With that, now that I've set the
context, let's bring our
esteemed panel
up on the stage to talk about
their vision for and experience
with Instant Apps.  So, folks,
come on up.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.  So why don't we kick
things off with each of you
introducing yourselves,
talking a bit about your
background and any other
thoughts you think might be
interesting for the  crowd.
>> Hello everyone. I'm Marcelo
Ferreiro.
I'm the Director of Engineering
at Jam
City and we were in charge of
creating
the Google Play Instant
experience for our game.
>> OLILVIA YU: I'm Olivia Yu,
vice president of platform
partnerships at King and we
created two Google Play Instant
experiences bubble with bubble
witch three and recently earlier
this
week on Tuesday with Candy Crush
Saga.
>> KYLE RUSHTON: My name is
Kyle
Rushton, the senior developer of
product management at Zynga and
I work in the product management
team.  I worked on the solitaire
and worlds
with friends 2 Google Play
Instant experiences.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Awesome.
Thank you for that.
So first question:  How do you
see instant and instant
experiences impacting the
overall gaming landscape?
>> MARCELO FERREIRO: So the
mobile
gaming landscape, it's more
competitive
than ever at this moment, and we
sea goog Google Play Instant as
a very
valuable tool for developers to
acquire
new users into their games, so I
think
that's the best part.
>> OLILVIA YU: So at King, I
think we think it can completely
change the way that games are
discovered, so there's a ton of
different untapped opportunities
that we're looking into, whether
it's
advertising,  cross-promotion in
our games, social, so there's a
bunch of different opportunities
that we haven't even looked at
for Google Play Instant,
so there's a lot of untapped
potential.
>> KYLE RUSHTON: I think in the
short term when thinking about
app store discovery we'll
ultimately see more consumers
trying games which will
ultimately lead to more installs
and longer and better engagement
but thinking longer term I think
it will allow developers to
reshape the way they think think
about discovery and think
outside the box about how to
bring the experience to
consumers in ways that are
outside the traditional app
store.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Awesome.
So a couple other questions here
for you  guys.  What instant use
cases have you tried?  And what
use cases are you most excited
about?
>> MARCELO FERREIRO: So for us,
we
build the first 10 levels of the
game
for users to play, and then they
are
able to carry over their
progress into the full app when
they install it.
So it's more like the core
gameplay that you made.  And in
the future, we see that we're
going to Explore probably
sharing the
game with your other -- with
your friends.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Right. So
this would be, like, a social
invite use  case?
>> MARCELO FERREIRO: Yes, yes.
>> OLILVIA YU: So I think I
mentioned earlier, I think we're
pretty excited about all the
different use cases.  Probably
specifically on the performance
marketing side.  Once it's
available.  And then also for
our side, also cross-promotion.
It's really important as you
brought up earlier, we have a
ton of lapsed players on Candy
Crush saga so it's a great way
for us to bring players back for
them to see everything that's
happened with the  game, all the
new features and for people to
remember about the game again.
So I think those are sort of the
main use cases we're pretty
excited about,
and social, as well as Marcelo
mentioned.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Seems to
be a common theme.
>> KYLE RUSHTON: To date we've
been focused almost exclusively
on Try Now and trying to
optimize conversion funnel
through app store.
What I'm most excited about is
we've already said social a few
times.
Part of my Zynga DNA is social
invites and sharing.
I think on native, driving
virality and social growth has
always been challenging on the
recipient side of
that experience, there's a lot
of friction for users to think
about what
they received, go to the app
tore store,
install the app, and potentially
find out what their friend was
trying to share with them but in
the world of instant where you
can just share that
experience, play a word in words
with
friends and open the game word
is transformative in the way we
talk about discovery and sharing
the app in the first place.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Common
theme, social good.  There's
lots of other opportunities I'd
love to hear you thoughts on.
But all the things you've
implemented, what's been the
impact you've seen?  And what do
you anticipate in the future
from the next project that you
do with Google Play Instant?
>> MARCELO FERREIRO: Well, I
think
social will be really important
in that sense.
Being able to just click and
being able to play the game,
that's going to be really
important.
It removes the friction of the
installation, which is where
people actually are eager to
play the game, and
they probably need to wait 10,
15, 20 seconds to download it,
and being able
to take advantage of that
eagerness, I think that's going
to be really important in the
future.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Thank you.
>> OLILVIA YU: So from our
side, we actually see a lot of
users like a high intent to
install and we've actually
seen a lot of users who played
the game
actually go to install bubble
witch 3 or Candy Crush saga so
that's what we're excited about
and if there's different ways to
continue to optimize the funnel
from
instant to installing the game.
>> KYLE RUSHTON: We've been
encouraged by the level of
engagement we've seen with the
Try Now experience and the
demand we're seeing from the
consumers of being really
interested, just check something
out and not necessarily download
the full experience.
But our focus has been purely on
driving installs and conversion,
looking forward in addition to
sort of moving forth that
experience, also look to drive
things like re-engagement and
reactivations, and other sort of
core metrics as part of the
experience beyond just
optimization of the installation
funnel.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: That makes
a lot of sense.  So we've heard
from you kind of like
what you've done, what the
impact has been.  But let's
shift the conversation to
talking about how you build the
instant
app, and how you design an
instant experience.
So let's start off with you,
Olivia.  What factors do you
think make for a
great instant experience?
>> OLILVIA YU: You're pretty
much playing instantly and to
make sure the player feels like
they're in pretty much the
experience right away and we
really picked as you've shown
earlier really exciting levels
so we wanted to make sure we had
really great exciting and
engaging levels for the user to
experience so that was for us
really important.  That's why
we've selected certain levels as
you can see so certain levels
have certain boosters, certain
features to make sure it's
really different for
every level that they
experience, within the Google
Play Instant experience.
>> KYLE RUSHTON: Yeah, so would
you restate the question?
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: So what
factors make for a great instant
experience?
>> KYLE RUSHTON: Oh yeah.
Sorry, missed it for a second
there.  Yes, expertly speed is
important, so getting people
immediately into the core
experience, I think probably
goes without saying but I also
think it's important to really
design for the use
case, so at Zynga, with
optimization of installs being
sort of our primary driver,
we're really trying to get an
experience that was concise and
short so that it ended in a
clear opportunity to
expose a user to installing the
full experience.
I think if you were doing
something
like a social invite or using it
for
cross-promotion or user
acquisition or different
channels you might have to think
about the design for that use
case
specifically, so I think use
case is
really important to understand,
and exactly what KPI you're
trying to drive when building
the experience, so it's probably
not necessarily a one size fits
all answer.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Gotcha.
Marcelo?
>> MARCELO FERREIRO: Well, for
us, what made sense was to as I
mentioned before,
build, like, the first part of
the game,
basically because we know it's
strong,
so we wanted to share that, and
having the possibility to then
move to
the full app and be able to
carry over
that progress, that was the use
case that we...
But we see in the future another
possibilities of making probably
other games we do at Jam City
lake testing different use cases
and optimize those for each
game.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: So I have
a follow-up for you.
So building a game that meets
the 10 megabyte size limit
sounds probably for many of you
to be pretty intimidating but
all of you have successfully
done something like that.  What
my question is for you is, as
you
built out the instant experience
for  Panapo, what are the kinds
of things you learned about both
that process as well
as maybe things you learned
about the
installed apps infrastructure,
and so forth?
>> MARCELO FERREIRO: So our
first idea
was to make the instant app 20
levels
long, being able to go back and
forth to the map, and then go to
the game and then go to the map
again.
But again, we realized that we
weren't going to achieve the
size limit goal
that we had, so at that point,
we got together with the team
and basically
decided to only do gameplay, and
do the first 10 levels.
So that enabled us to remove a
lot of
textures, scenes that we weren't
using,
localization strings that need
to be
stripped off, and what we
learned is
that every little thing that you
can
remove from the app, remove it,
because it's going to be
important.
Remove the plugins, remove the
localizations that you don't
use.
Even the smallest  prefab, it's
important to take it out.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: It's all
cut out.
>> MARCELO FERREIRO: Yeah, so
take away everything.
We try to do it in a way where
we
could build it on top of the
regular
game, so we benefit from
changing -- from the changes
that we made in the
full app, so I would also
recommend that, if possible.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: You're
saying that through that
process, you were able to make
optimizations that then impacted
your full game?  Is that right?
>> MARCELO FERREIRO: Yes.
In fact, there were two things
that we benefit from building
the instant app.
One was we improved the way we
were
making animations and that made
the
application run mather, and with
a reduced memory footprint, so
we
basically in the full app, we
gained
memory and we gained
performance, so it was truly
beneficial.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: That's
awesome.  And, kale, why don't
you talk a little bit about your
experience.
You converted at least a couple
of games that I've had an
opportunity to play.
What was your experience like
and how did you do that?
>> KYLE RUSHTON: Fortunately in
the case of Zynga solitaire the
full app was
around the 10 megabyte mark.  In
the case of words with friends
2, I think it was, goes back to
sort of like the design piece of
it as well was
really just having a clear focus
of what we wanted to bring to
consumers.
So for  us, we launched words
with friends 2 about six months
ago.  One of the new features
was a feature
called solo series which allows
users to play against AI powered
bots.  We thought that was a
good match so we focused
exclusively on bringing a subset
of solo series to the instant
app.  By having that clear focus
we're able to remove a lot of
other stuff that was tangential
unrelated so we could reduce the
app size and build a really
clean experience without a lot
of the other I won't call it
fluff but aspects of the app.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Awesome.
So to synthesize that, you're
saying that you can cut out
let's say lots of levels but
another thing is to focus on one
particular slice of the
experience.
>> KYLE RUSHTON: Yeah, exactly.
That was a good summary.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Cool.
Your thoughts, Olivia?
>> OLILVIA YU: So I think for
us we just focused a lot on the
gameplay and then we took out
the saga map.  We don't have any
other features.  A lot of our
games always have a narrative in
the beginning so we took
everything out so it was only
just focused on the  gameplay.
That's what we wanted to focus
on.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Makes a
lot of sense.  And we've heard
similar things from a
lot of our other partners, as
well,
that's either stripping out
assets or choosing a select
gameplay but things really could
get some additional context from
you up here.
So I wanted to particularly talk
to you
about some of the challenges
related to
developing a instant experience
in Unity and what are some of
the things you ended up having
to do and learn through that
process?
>> MARCELO FERREIRO: Well, as
you mentioned before, the
biggest challenge
for us was size, so we did it as
I mentioned before, we needed to
change
the way we are doing animations,
because
what we were using at the time,
the what it was producing, they
were bigger and
they were also taking up a lot
of memory in the game.
And after that, we also needed
to, like, refactor certain parts
of the Code to be able to only
use the scene of the gameplay.
I think those were the two
biggest challenges that we
needed to make, but
in the end, we ended up with
a more modernized application,
and we
were able to benefit from that
in a technical way, also.
So it was a win-win for us.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Excellent.
And so looking forward, overall,
what kind of developments do you
see emerging
in the instant gaming space in
the coming years?
You can go as far as in the
future as you would like but
love to hear your thoughts on
how you see the whole space
evolving.
>> MARCELO FERREIRO: I think
that this
is going to be like probably
I want to say the future of
acquisition.  Also the social
part of being able to
share a link and start playing
right away.  That's probably
going to be the future apps that
we're going to see, and of
course, we're going to benefit
from  that.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Awesome.
>> OLILVIA YU: I think as you
mentioned especially with new
famous coming so there's also a
way, you know, to also
fully leverage the
pre-registration on Google Play
so players can actually try the
game before they pre-register
and actually install it so I
think that's another way and
then depending on where you are
in the stage for your game,
there could be different instant
games experiences.
>> KYLE RUSHTON: I'm really
excited to
see what the creativity of game
developers will bring to Google
Instant and I think there will
be some breakout
mechanic built on top of Google
Play Instant that to date would
not be possible so I think once
you think about it from a design
perspective and what you can
bring once there's no friction
between a current user and
potential users or re-activated
user you'll be able to build new
mechanics on
top of that that are breakouout.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: We now
have about 10 minutes left which
means we could do
some Q&A, if you in the audience
are excited about that.  I'm
sure we would love to answer
your questions.
See if that mic works.
>> Hi, I'm Chris, I'm from Hong
Kong.  We're a game publisher.
I'm just  wondering, I think
kale
mentioned about re-- Kyle
mentioned
about engagement I was wondering
if you
did a different experience with
users from organic  users.
>> KYLE RUSHTON: Yeah so to
date we haven't specifically
tried a use case related to
re-engagement but if we were we
would design a new experience
for that so if we were releasing
a new
feature we could put the content
with that feature into Google
Play Instant and introduce that
to a consumer through instant
but I definitely think for us,
when looking at install
optimization
that wouldn't be the appropriate
experience we're trying to bring
back someone accustomed to
playing the game.  We haven't
tried that to date but it's
something we're considering.
>> So you're more for Ben as
well you're able to distinguish
the engaged users coming back
versus new users, right?
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: There's a
couple of different ways I
imagine this working
but in one scenario it's about
how you target your users,
right?
If you have existing channels to
reach people that are already
playing your
game, then you could have some
certainty
that it's going to be the
already playing your game type
of user that you're exposing to
the instant experience.
And if you're -- the Try Now
button on the Store is a good
fit for new users in many cases,
right?  So I think that you can
handle the
targeting on the basis of how
you identify your users, and
look to see how you can get the
instant experience in front of
them.
>> Thanks.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: We've got
some more people coming up here?
>> KYLE RUSHTON: I would add to
that, ultimately any channel
you're currently using for
marketing for the most part
could be used in a use case for,
I believe we mentioned, for
cross promotion and as was just
noted but the targeting would
come from the developer
themselves.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Excellent.
>> Can I do one?
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Go for it.
>> As a developer, I have a
design question.
I'm curious, in your experience
of instant apps so far, did you
find that
you had to design a custom pitui
for the instant app to get users
so they could play it really
quickly?  Because you obviously
have limited time to teach them
controls.
>> BENJAMIN FRENKEL: The
question is whether or not we,
or you, had to build
a custom Ptui for your instant
speans.
>> KYLE RUSHTON: The short
answer is we did not.  In the
case of solitaire we benefited
from people understanding how to
play solitaire.  But for words
with friends 2, the experience
we drop users into which was
a solo series was we felt
self-explanatory enough where a
user
could just pick it up off the
bat, as we
didn't have a custom PTUI for
our
instant experience.
>> OLILVIA YU: Same for Candy
Crush.